BEGIN AS A SUB COMMITTEE.
GOOD AFTERNOON I WANT TO WELCOME
LINDSEY MITCHELL THE NEW
REPUBLICAN CAUCUS CONSULTANT
COVERING THE COMMITTEE.
WELCOME TO LINDSEY.
SO TODAY WE HAVE TO MEASURES ON
THE AGENDA.
PLEASE NOTE THAT OUR GENERAL
GUIDELINE FOR BILLS HEARD IN
THIS COMMITTEE IS TO ALLOW
TESTIMONY. FOR TWO WITNESSES FOR
SUPPORT AND TWO WITNESSES IN THE
OPPOSITION TO SPEAK EACH FOR TWO
MINUTES.
STAKEHOLDER GROUPS AND ENTITIES
THAT ARE NEITHER IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION WILL BE ALLOWED TO
GIVE TESTIMONY. FOR NO MORE THAN
TWO MINUTES.
WHEN I CALL FOR TWEETERS?
THE MEASURE HAS MORE THAN TWO
ENTITIES THAT WIENER CATEGORY
ONLY TWO WILL BE ALLOWED. TO
SPEAK FOR TWO MINUTES EACH.
AND FIRST ON THE AGENDA AT
AGENDA ITEM ONE AS BE
[inaudible]
TWO ZERO SIX SENATORS CAN.
WELCOME QUITE JOINT AUTHORS
[inaudible]
WELCOME BOTH.
YOU MAY BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY
CENTERS CAN.
YOU SO MUCH -- MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS -- ARE MY JOIN NOT THERE
WILL ALSO BE OPENING AND THEN WE
WILL HEAR FROM OUR WITNESSES AND
I HAVE A TECHNICAL EXPERT IN
CASE THERE ARE QUESTIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE.
SO SB TWO OH SIX FIRST I WILL BE
TAKING THE AMENDMENTS THAT -- WE
HAVE DISCUSSED WITH THE
COMMITTEE.
THERE WAS AMENDMENTS RECOGNIZED
THAT OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGE
SYSTEM IS NOT A MEMBER OF THE NC
TWO WAY.
AND THAT'S IS NOT TECHNICALLY
GOVERNED BY THEIR RULES -- AND
SO THE BILL ALLOWS FOR THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM -- TO
FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO ESTABLISH
A STAKEHOLDER GROUP THAT
INVOLVES THE COMMUNICORP SYSTEM
PLUS SOME APPOINTEES OF THE
LEGISLATURE. TO DISCUSS THEIR
RULE CHANGE -- TO IF THIS BILL
IS SUCCESSFUL TO BE COMPARABLE
TO THE ROLE CHANGE THAT WE ARE
THAN TRYING TO AFFECT FOR OUR
OTHER CAMPUSES.
RECOGNIZING THAT AGAIN AS
MENTIONED THAT THE COMMITTEE
CALLED SYSTEM IS DIFFERENT AND
IT'S ALSO A TWO YEAR SYSTEM SO.
I APPRECIATE THE INTERACTION
WITH THE CHAIR TO MAKE THOSE
GOOD AMENDMENTS.
NOW.
SB TWO OH SIX WHAT THIS BILL
DOES IS GIVE OUR STUDENT
ATHLETES THE SAME RIGHTS THAT
OLYMPIC ATHLETES HAVE.
AND THE SAME RIGHT THE EACH AND
EVERYONE OF US HAVE UNDER
CALIFORNIA LAW AND THAT IS THE
RIGHT TO OUR OWN NAME IMAGE AND
LIKENESS NO ONE ELSE UNDER
CALIFORNIA LAW CAN MARKET YOUR
NAME IMAGE OR LIKENESS.
WITHOUT YOUR PERMISSION.
ONLY STUDENT ATHLETES ARE
PREVENTED FROM THE ACT.
SB TWO OH SIX DOES NOT REQUIRE
SCHOOLS TO PAY ATHLETES DIRECTLY.
PURELY GIVES THEM THE RIGHT TO
THEIR OWN NAME IMAGE AND
LIKENESS SOME ATHLETES MAY
CHOOSE NOT TO EXERCISE THAT
RIGHT.
OTHERS WILL.
BUT I ASK YOU.
IMAGINE IF ANY OTHER BILLION
DOLLAR INDUSTRY. FOR EXAMPLE TV
OR MOVIES RELY.
ON COLLEGE STUDENTS AS THEIR
PRIMARY SOURCE OF TALENT FOR THE
REVENUE OF THEIR INDUSTRY YET
DENIED THOSE STUDENTS ANY
COMPENSATION.
THERE WOULD BE UNIVERSAL OUTCRY
NOW SOME OF YOU MAY BE THINKING
BUT WAIT A MINUTE.
STUDENT ATHLETES GET
SCHOLARSHIPS.
IF YOU LOOK AT ALL OF OUR
COLLEGES OWN DATA.
OVER HALF OF STUDENT ATHLETES
GET NO SCHOLARSHIP IN OUR
PRESENTATION TO THE LAST
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE WE HAD ERIN
CAFARO.
A ROWER FOR CAL. TWO TIME
OLYMPIAN [inaudible]
WHO?
AT HER FOR YEARS A CAL.
SHE WROTE ALL FOUR YEARS
QUALIFIED FOR THE OLYMPICS SHE
DID NOT GET A SCHOLARSHIP TO HER
SENIOR YEAR AND IT WAS PARTIAL.
AND YET WITH HER ROWING SCHEDULE.
AND HER ACADEMICS SHE COULD NOT
HAVE A PART TIME JOB.
SHE HAD NO ABILITY TO REALLY
COVER ALL OF HEREXPENSES.
ON SO OF COURSE SHE WAS HERE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL --
ANYWAY.
YOU HAVE A LETTER FROM THE
FORMER CHIEF OPERATING OFFICER
OF THE NC TWO WAY DâN BOGAN WHO
IS ALSO A FORMER VICE CHANCELLOR
OF BUSINESS ADMINISTRATION AT UC
BERKELEY.
WHO IS IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL IN
WHO WRITES THAT ONE OF THE KEY
REASONS THAT HE BACKS THE BILL
IS BECAUSE?
DE NC TO RAISE RULES ARE
CONTRADICTORY TO A CORE TENET OF
THEIR OWN BYLAWS.
AND THEIR OWN BYLAWS STATE.
THAT THEIR RULES MUST ASSURE
THAT ATHLETIC PARTICIPANTS ARE
NOT TREATED DIFFERENTLY FROM ANY
OTHER MEMBER OF THE STUDENT BODY.
AND YET BY DENYING STUDENTS ANY
ABILITY TO MARKET THEIR OWN NAME
IMAGE AND LIKENESS THEY'RE
TREATING THEM DIFFERENTLY.
AND I WANT TO MAKE A SIMPLE
POINT BECAUSE VERY OFTEN WE
THINK IMMEDIATELY OF THE ELITE
ATHLETE AND WE THINK WELL THIS
IS JUST GOING TO ALLOW A FEW
STUDENTS TO MAKE A LOT OF MONEY.
BUT LET'S GIVE THE EXAMPLE OF
THAT YOUNG PERSON WHO IS THE
STAR ATHLETE FROM THEIR SMALL
TOWN.
AND THEY THEY ARE THE BIGGEST
THING THAT THEY'RE THEY'RE JUST
CELEBRATED IN THEIR SMALL TOWN.
AND THEY GO OFF TO COLLEGE IN
THERE MAYBE IN A MINOR SPORT.
THEY DON'T GET A SCHOLARSHIP BUT
PERHAPS THERE.
A LOCAL CAR DEALERSHIP OR THEIR
CORNICE CLUBBER THEIR ROTARY
CLUB WANTS TO SPONSOR THEM HELP
THEM SUPPORT THEM TO GO TO
SCHOOL.
THAT'S STUDENT WOULD BE DENIED.
ANOTHER EXAMPLE YOU'RE THE HIGH
SCHOOL FOOTBALL STAR.
YOU'RE NOT THAT GOOD FOR GOING
OFF TO PRO OR EVEN BEING AN
ELITE SCHOOL BUT YOU'RE REALLY
IMPORTANT YOUR TOWN.
YOU CAN'T COME BACK AND COACH
FOR TRAIN THE OTHER HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS FOR ANY KIND OF
COMPENSATION YOU CAN'T RUN A
SPORTS CAMP FOR ANY COMPENSATION.
ALL BECAUSE OF THE NC TO A ROLES
WHY WOULD WE DENY THAT.
AND ESPECIALLY WHEN WITH THE
AMOUNT OF PRESSURE ON STUDENT
ATHLETES IN THE TIME IT TAKES
FOR THEM TO KEEP UP WITH THEIR
SPORT.
THEY REALLY CAN'T HAVE PART TIME
JOBS.
SO LET ME STOP AND TURN IT OVER
TO MY AUTHOR.
SENATOR BRADFORD.
THANK YOU MISTER MEMBERS AND
FIRST LET ME THANK -- SOONER
SKINNER FOR LEADERSHIP ON THIS
ISSUE SB TOOL -- SIX I WOULD
LIKE TO SAY IS TO CIVIL RIGHTS
ISSUE OF TODAY WHEN IT COMES.
TO ATHLETES AND SPORTS HERE AND
AMERICA.
IT'S ABOUT FAIRNESS THIS IS NOT
A ISSUE OF SPORTS IT'S ABOUT
FAIRNESS IT'S ABOUT ALLOWING
THESE YOUNG MEN AND WOMEN TO
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THAT SMALL
WINDOW.
THAT MIGHT PROJECTED PRESENT
ITSELF FOR THEM TO MONETIZE
THEIR NAME IMAGE AND LIKENESS.
AND ADDS SENATOR SKINNER STATED
THE MAJORITY OF THESE ATHLETES
WILL NEVER GO PRO.
ONLY 2% OF COLLEGE ATHLETES EVER
MAKE IT TO THE PRO LEVEL AND
MANY OF THEM HAVE CAREERS LESS
THAN THREE YEARS.
CHAU SEEING THAT AS A COLLEGE
ATHLETE WERE YOU ARE FILLING
ARENAS AND STADIUMS ALL ACROSS
THE COUNTRY WERE USE.
SELLING SEATS AND HELPING SELL
MERCHANDISE THAT YOU BENEFIT NOT
ONE IOTA OTHER THAN YES YOU GET
A SCHOLARSHIP [inaudible]
BUT I WENT TO COLLEGE WITH
PLENTY OF SCHOLARSHIP ATHLETES
WHO STRUGGLE TO MAKE ENDS MEET
FROM MONTH TO MONTH.
MANY BORROWED MONEY FROM ME ON A
REGULAR BASIS TO PUT.
GAS IN THE CAR IF THEY HAD A CAR
AND MANY OF THEM DID HAVE CARS
BUT THE BY MAIL OR SOMETHING OF
THAT NATURE SO A SCHOLARSHIP IN
AND OF ITSELF.
DOESN'T TAKE CARE OF ALL THE
NECESSITIES THAT YOU NEED TO
SURVIVE -- OUTSIDE A ROOM AND
BOARD AND I TUITION TO LOT MORE
EXPENSES AS YOU KNOW TO GO TO
COLLEGE NOWADAYS SO -- AGAIN
THIS IS THE ISSUE OF FAIRNESS
AND AS I SAID CIVIL RIGHTS
BECAUSE OF 3% OF THE
UNDERGRADUATE POPULATION AFRICAN
AMERICANS MAKE UP JUST 3% OF THE
UNDERGRADUATE -- Và UNIVERSITY
IN COLLEGE POPULATION BUT THEY
MAKE UP OVER 50%.
OF THE ATHLETES THAT PLAYED
FOOTBALL AND BASKETBALL AT THESE
MAJOR UNIVERSITIES MANY OF THESE
INDIVIDUALS COME FROM LOW INCOME
FAMILIES.
BUT THEY'RE RECRUITED BY COACHES
NOW WILL MAKE MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS COACHES NOW MAKE MORE
THAN COLLEGE PRESIDENTS.
COACHES WHO ARE ABLE.
TO MONETIZE THEIR IMAGE IN THEIR
LIKENESS BECAUSE MANY OF THEM
HAVE ENDORSEMENT DEALS.
AND THAT.
MAKES IT VERY ATTRACTIVE AND
THAT'S PART OF THE NEGOTIATIONS
OF COME TO ME OF THESE COLLEGES
THEIR ABILITY TO MONETIZE INTO --
ADVERTISING AND MARKETING AND
OTHER -- ENDORSEMENTS ON THE
SIDE -- TALK SHOWS PODCASTS YOU
NAME IT -- COACHES TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THIS ATHLETES CAN'T
HAVE THAT SAME OPPORTUNITY SO.
AGAIN -- THIS IS ABOUT.
AGAIN FAIRNESS AND MAKING SURE
THAT THESE ATHLETES DON'T
STRUGGLE TO STAND IN COLLEGE AND
AS SENATOR SKINNER STATED THIS
WILL NOT AFFECT THE UNIVERSITY
NOT ONE IOTA NOT ONE DIME
BECAUSE OF HIS SPONSOR WANTS.
TO PAY THEM FOR THAT AGAIN IT
DOESN'T COME OUT OF THE COLLEGE
KATIE WHATSOEVER COLLEGES WILL
NOT BE PAYING FOR THAT IT WOULD
BE THE INDIVIDUAL.
COMPANY OUR BUSINESS WHO FEELS
THAT THIS INDIVIDUALS ARE WORTHY
OF AN ENDORSEMENT DEAL OR ARE
THE SPONSORSHIP.
AND IT IS ALSO GOING TO HAVE
PEOPLE SAY WELL IT'S GOING TO
ENCOURAGE FOLKS TO LEAVE COLLEGE
YOUNG STUDENTS TO STAY IN
COLLEGE.
BECAUSE AGAIN IF THEY CAN
MONETIZE THEIR WORK WHILE
THEY'RE THEY WON'T BE DOING THE
ONE AND DONE WE ALL.
READ ABOUT PEOPLE LIKE DIANE
WILLIAMSON. ONE AND DONE.
THE LAST BASKETBALL GAME HE
PLAYED IN TICKETS SOLD FOR
THIRTY FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS A
SEAT.
THEY SURELY WASN'T PAYING TO SEE
THE BLUE DEVIL MASCOT THEY WERE
COMING TO SEE CYAN WILLIAMS TO
PLAY BASKETBALL.
THESE KIDS FILL ARENAS THEY FILL
SEATS AND AGAIN THIS IS
OPPORTUNITY FOR THEM TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THAT SMALL WINDOW.
AND AS WE SEE IN BASKETBALL MANY
OF THESE KIDS SOMETIMES SKIP
COLLEGE ALTOGETHER BECAUSE OF
THE MONETARY OPPORTUNITIES IN
THE NBA WE SIDE WITH THE LEBRON
JAMES WE SAW WOULD KOBE BRYANT.
KEVIN GARNETT.
IN MANY OTHERS WHO JUST BYPASS
COLLEGE ALTOGETHER BECAUSE OF
THE FINANCIAL NEEDS IN THE BE
ABLE TO HELP A SISTER FAMILY SO.
AGAIN.
BUT THIS I I WISH AS I STATED
THIS BILL DOES MORE BUT I THINK
IT'S A COMMONSENSE MEASURE
THAT'S ABOUT FAIRNESS AND
OPPORTUNITY AND I HOUSE AFTER
PROPER TIME FOR RIVAL.
THANK YOU.
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT LET ME
INTRODUCE SO QUICKLY SO THEY
DON'T USE THAT TIME.
WE HAVE -- HEALY HODSON WHO IS A
STANFORD -- VOLLEYBALL PLAYER.
AND WE HAVE RUSSELL A **** WHO
IS THE CURRENT NFL LEFT TACKLE
FOR THE LA CHARGERS AND A SUPER
BOWL CHAMPION [inaudible]
WELCOME.
HELLO OF I'M SORRY BEFORE YOU
BEGIN WE'RE GOING TO ESTABLISH A
QUORUM. ONE ONE SIX MEDINA
PRESENT CHOI.
ARAMBULA.
BLOOM.
GABRIEL [inaudible]
IRWIN KILEY [inaudible]
LEVINE [inaudible]
LOW [inaudible]
PATTERSON.
SANTIAGO.
WEBER [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
THAT. FOR A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
WELCOME.
AND YOU MAY BEGIN EACH WILL HAVE
TWO MINUTES.
GOOD AFTERNOON -- I'M A FORMER
STANFORD WOMEN'S VOLLEYBALL
PLAYER SENATOR SKIN IT SKINNER
MENTIONED -- COMING OUT OF HIGH
SCHOOL I WAS THE TOP RANKED
RECRUIT IN THE NATION AND A
PLAYER ON THE USA WOMEN'S
NATIONAL TEAM.
I WENT ON TO EARN ALL AMERICAN
THE NATIONAL FRESHMAN OF THE
YEAR HONORS DURING MY FIRST YEAR
AT STANFORD.
UNFORTUNATELY FOR ME HOWEVER.
I SUFFERED TWO CONCUSSIONS AND
ENSUING COMPLICATIONS DURING MY
FIRST SEASON AT STANFORD WHICH
LED TO MY MEDICAL RETIREMENT AT
AGE TWENTY MY CAREER WAS OVER
BEFORE IT EVEN STARTED.
LIKE MOST COLLEGE ATHLETES MY
FAMILY HAS MADE MANY FINANCIAL
SACRIFICES OVER THE YEARS IN
ORDER TO HELP ME PROGRESS IS
BOTH THE STUDENT AND AN ATHLETE.
BUT NOW THAT MY CAREER IS OVER
IT IS CLEAR THAT EVEN BEING ONE
OF THE TOP PLAYERS IN A SPORT
WITH PROFESSIONAL OPPORTUNITIES
DOES NOT GUARANTEE THAT THOSE
INVESTMENT OF TIME.
AND MONEY WILL PAY OFF.
THE NCAA PROFITS FROM THE
PERFORMANCE AND LABOR OF MINORS
AND YOUNG ADULTS WHILE DENYING
THOSE SAME PERFORMERS THE RIGHT
TO EARN MONEY BASED ON THEIR
ATHLETIC TALENTS AND SUCCESSES
THROUGH OTHER MEANS.
IN FACT THE NCAA HAS A MONOPOLY
ON THE ADVERTISING AND PUBLICITY
RIGHTS OF ALL AMATEUR ATHLETES
IN THE COUNTRY.
WELL SB TWO OH SIX WOULD HELP
ALL CALIFORNIA ATHLETES IT WOULD
PARTICULARLY BENEFIT WOMEN.
THE END SAY IS STILL THE PREMIER
ATHLETIC PLATFORM FOR MOST
FEMALE ATHLETES IN AMERICA BUT
UNIVERSITIES HAVE CHOSEN TO MAKE
MEN'S FOOTBALL AND BASKETBALL
TEAMS THEIR PRIORITIES.
FEMALE ATHLETES WHO ARE THE BEST
IN THEIR SPORTS TO PHYSICALLY
HAVE FEWER PROFESSIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES AFTER COLLEGE AS
THEIR MALE COUNTERPARTS IN WOULD
BENEFIT QUICK GREATLY FROM BEING
ABLE TO MARKET THEMSELVES DURING
COLLEGE. FOR THE 98% OF COLLEGE
ATHLETES THAT WILL NEVER GO PRO
COLLEGE IS THE ONLY TIME THEY
HAVE TO PROFIT OFF THEIR HARD
EARNED ATHLETICS SUCCESSES AND
THEY ARE CURRENTLY DENIED THAT
OPPORTUNITY.
NO OTHER COLLEGE STUDENTS ARE
TREATED THIS WAY MUSICIANS
DANCERS ACTORS AND OTHER COLLEGE
STUDENTS WITH ACT ATHLETIC
ARTISTIC OR ENTREPRENEUR YOUR
TALENTS HAVE NO RESTRICTIONS ON
THEIR EARNING CAPACITIES.
IN HIGH SCHOOL I HAD TO TURN
DOWN STIPENDS ENDORSEMENTS AND
EVEN A TV SHOW PRIOR TO COLLEGE
IN ORDER TO STAY ELIGIBLE TO
PLAY IN THE NCAA.
I WAS ON TRACK TO BE ONE OF THE
FEW COLLEGE ATHLETES THAT WOULD
HAVE HAD A PROFESSIONAL CAREER.
BUT BECAUSE I RECEIVED A CAREER
ENDING IN LIFE CHANGING BRAIN
INJURY DURING COLLEGE.
I NEVER GOT TO SEE ALL OF MY
HARD WORK IN MY FAMILY
SACRIFICES PAY OFF AND I'M NOT
ALONE MORE THAN 50% OF DIVISION
ONE COLLEGE ATHLETE SUFFER FROM
CHRONIC SPORTS INJURIES.
AND WILL BE FACING PAIN AND
MEDICAL BILLS FOR THE RIGHTS OF
THEIR LIVES BECAUSE OF THEIR
PARTICIPATION IN NCAA SPORTS.
MY HOPE IS THAT SB TWO OH SIX
WOULD BEGIN TO PROVIDE ATHLETES
OF EVERY BACKGROUND A CHANCE TO
EARN BACK EVEN JUST A LITTLE OF
WHAT THEY SACRIFICE FOR THEIR
SCHOOLS.
EVEN EVERY SINGLE ATHLETE
DESERVES A CHANCE TO MONETIZE
HIS OR HER HARD WORK AND TALENT
IF YOU'RE STATE SHE CHOOSES TO
DO SO.
IT IS NEVER ENOUGH TO HAVE LESS
THAN EQUAL PUBLICITY RIGHTS OR
BE DENIED THE ECONOMIC AND CIVIL
RIGHTS PROTECTIONS AFFORDED TO
ALL OTHER AMERICANS.
THE COMMITTEE TO VOTE YES THANK
YOU.
YEP -- JUNE TWENTY EIGHTH TWO
DOT TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN IT WAS
A VERY SPECIAL DAY FOR ME.
AT FIVE THIRTY SEVEN FIVE THIRTY
SEVEN EIGHT POUNDS THREE OUNCES
MCPHERSON WAS BORN.
WHILE HOLDING MY NEWBORN SON
AMOUNTS FOR THE FIRST TIME ASK
MYSELF A QUESTION WHICH I
BELIEVE EVERYONE AT THE POINT IN
THEIR LIFE TO ASK.
WHAT ARE YOU GONNA DO THE LIFE
THAT YOU HAVE LEFT WHEN YOU'RE
EXPOSED OPPORTUNITY GIVES YOU
OPTIONS OPTIONS REQUIRE
DECISIONS AS REFLECT ON THIS
DECISION THAT WE MAKE TODAY?
HOW SHAPE THE FUTURE ARE JUST
COMMITTEE TO RECOGNIZE ENORMOUS
STAKES THIS BILL PRESENTS -- FOR
COUNTLESS ATHLETES MARK EMMERT
OF THE NC DOUBLE A CLAIM TO
CALIFORNIA'S BILL TO RETURN THE
RIGHTS.
AND NAMES IMAGES AND LIKE MR
COLLEGE ATHLETES QUOTE THREATENS
TO ALTER MATERIALLY PRINCIPLES
OF INTERCOLLEGIATE ATHLETICS HE
IS ABSOLUTELY CORRECT.
THE SO CALLED PRINCIPLES OF
INSTEAD OF WHAT SHOULD BE
MATERIALLY ALTERED AS THEY ARE
FAR FROM VIRTUOUS.
THEY ARE IN FACT ROOTED IN LONG
STANDING PRACTICES OF
EXPLOITATION OPPRESSION AND A
BLACK LABOR WHICH HAS EMBEDDED
IN BEEN EMBEDDED AMERICAN
HISTORY SINCE THE INSTITUTION OF
SLAVERY.
ABOUT ONE HUNDRED SIXTY TWO
YEARS AGO THE INFAMOUS DRED
SCOTT DECISION OF THE SUPREME
COURT HELD THAT THE CONSTITUTION
WAS NOT MEANT TO INCLUDE
AMERICAN CITIZENSHIP PROVIDE
PEOPLE.
REGARDLESS OF WHETHER THEY WERE
ENSLAVED OR FREE THEREFORE THE
RIGHTS AND PRIVILEGES IT CONFERS
UPON AMERICAN CITIZEN SHOULD NOT
APPLY TO BLACK PEOPLE A DECADE
LATER.
THE THIRTEEN THE MEMBER
ABOLISHED SLAVERY AND
INVOLUNTARY SERVITUDE EXCEPT AS
PUNISHMENT FOR CRIME WERE OF THE
PARTY SHALL HAVE BEEN DULY.
CONVICTED BUDGET DEFICIT
DESCRIBE HOW TO ACCEPT INTO THE
THE LETTER TO RISE A WIDESPREAD
CONVICT LEASING SYSTEM.
WHICH UNDERMINE THE FUNCTION OF
THE THIRTEEN MM HE SAID I QUOTE.
THE STATE CRIME REPORT MADE TO
MAINTAIN STATE CONVICTS WITHIN
PRISON WALLS HAS THE CONVICTS
RELEASED OUT THE WORK FOR
ROADWAY -- CONTRACTORS MINING
COMPANIES AND THOSE WHO FARM
LARGE PLANTATIONS. 90% OF THE
COMPLEX DOUG WAS ONE THAT WERE
BLACK.
TODAY THE FREE MARKET SYSTEM IN
THE UNITED STATES WORK FOR
EVERYONE BUT TWO GROUPS OF
PEOPLE THE APTLY AND THE
PRESIDENT.
BOTH PARTIES TO PROVIDE OF ROOM
FOOD BOARD.
AND SOME EVEN GET EDUCATION BUT
MOST IMPORTANTLY BOTH PARTIES
ARE DENIED THE RIGHT TO
SIGNIFICANT COMPENSATION FOR THE
LABOR.
BY NO MEANS AM I SUGGESTING THAT
STUDENT ATHLETES ARE SLAVES
AGAINST THEIR WILL.
BUT I CAN'T HELP BUT TO WONDER
WHAT CRIME HAVE THEY COMMITTED
TO DESERVE BEING ALIENATED FROM
THE FINANCIAL FRUITS OF THEIR
LABOR WHAT IS A FREE MARKET
SYSTEM WORK FOR EVERYONE.
BUT EXCEPT THE ATHLETE.
IN A LETTER SUBMITTED TO THIS
COMMITTEE COMMITTEE MY MENTOR
AND FORMER NBA MVP EXACT
DIRECTOR CHARLES GRANTHAM
HIGHLIGHTS HOW THIS TO NATALIE
TURN BEGAN AS A WAY FOR INTO THE
WAY TO AVOID WORKERS
COMPENSATION CLAIMS.
THIS RATIONALE WAS EMITTED BY
NONE OTHER THAN THE PERSON WHO
INVENTED THE TERM WALTER BYERS.
EVEN IF WE CONCEDE.
THAT WAS ARGUMENT THAT STUDENT
ATHLETES ARE STUDENTS FIRST AT
THE SECOND LET'S EXAMINE THE
RIGHTS OF THE AVERAGE STUDENT.
EFFORT STUDENT WORKS ARE JOB ON
CAMPUS THEY'RE ALLOWED TO MAKE
AN HOUR'S PROBABLY WAGE IF THE
STUDENT IS GOOD A CHEMISTRY AND
CHOOSE THE TUTOR.
THEY CAN CHARGE MONEY FOR THIS
STUDENTS ARE ALLOWED TO MAKE
MONEY FROM THEIR PRESS
SPECIALIZED SKILLS.
BUT STUDENT ATHLETES EXPLICITLY
PROHIBITED ARE PROHIBITED FROM
DOING.
ANYTHING WITH A SPECIALIZED
SKILLS FOR MOMENT [inaudible]
PLEASE PONDERED.
WHOSE RIGHTS TO THE ATHLETES
HAVE MORE SIMPLISTIC.
SLAVES OF PRISONERS OR THE
STUDENT BODY.
THIS RIGHT THIS FIGHT OVER THIS
BILL IS A SOLELY -- ABOUT MAKING
MONEY IT'S NOT ABOUT
CHAMPIONSHIPS IT'S IT'S IT'S
ABOUT IT'S NOT ABOUT SCHOOL
SPIRIT.
IT'S ABOUT HOT ONGOING FIGHT --
FOR THAT WE SERVICE SPECIALLY
ASK A COUPLE PEOPLE HIS NATION.
IS ABOUT BASIC CIVIL LIBERTIES.
AND THAT REPRESSIVE MEASURES
STILL EXIST UNTIL TUESDAY.
DO WE AS A SOCIETY.
SEE COLLEGE ATHLETES AS FULL
CITIZENS OR SUGAR LABOR CONTINUE
TO BE SHAMEFUL EXPORTED USING
OUTDATED LOGIC THAT'S ROOTED IN
SLAVERY.
ARE THE ASSETS THAT EXIST FOR
MERE PRESENCE. FOR OTHER HUMAN
BEINGS WHICH HAVE THE SAME
RIGHTS AS ANYONE ELSE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
WITH THIS IS IN OPPOSITION NOT
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OTHER
SUPPORT -- I'M SORRY.
OTHER SUPPORT THANK YOU CENTERS
SKINNER.
HI KAYLA INDIAN WITH THE
ALLIANCE FOR BOYS AND MEN OF
COLOR AT POLICY LINK PROUD CO
SPONSORS IN ABSOLUTE SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MAP BROUGHT
FOR THE TEAMSTERS IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
SELENA PRIOR CALIFORNIA STATE IN
DOUBLE ACP IN SUPPORT.
MARIO GUERRERO ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
STRONG SUPPORT.
JULIE WATERS WITHOUT ME THIRTY
TWO NINETY NINE A STRONG SUPPORT.
MAYWASHINGTON WITH CAL STATE
STUDENT ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
QUESTION IS ROBBIE WITH THE UC
STUDENT ASSOCIATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
NEIL SWEENEY UAW LOCALS TWENTY
FIFTY FIVE AND FIFTY EIGHT TEN
REPRESENTING TEASE READERS AND
TUTORS AND POSTDOCTORAL SCHOLARS
AT UC AND CSU [inaudible]
IN SUPPORT.
REMOTE HUMOR WITH THE NATIONAL
COLLEGE PLAYERS ASSOCIATION
WHICH IS A PROPER CODES BOUNCER
IN SUPPORT.
I'M ANDY SCHWARTZ ON A
CALIFORNIA SMALL BUSINESS OWNER
AND ALSO A CO SPONSOR IN SUPPORT.
I'M JOHN RUN IN WITH THE UC F.
T. AND I AM IN SUPPORT.
NOW WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION AND
IF WE COULD PLEASE MAKE ROOM FOR
.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN MEDINA
COMMITTEE MEMBERS TYLER REGULAR
BE AFTER THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA -- WE ARE
RESPECTFULLY IN OPPOSITION I
WANT TO THANK THE TWO FORMER
TESTIMONIES.
WE APPRECIATE YOU SHARE THE
AUTHOR'S INTEREST -- IN STUDENT
OUT THE WELFARE YOU SEE TAKES
GREAT PRIDE IN BEING A LEADER IN
THIS AREA I UC'S COMMITTED TO
PROTECTING SEA WELFARE OF
STUDENT ATHLETES IN A TWENTY
SIXTEEN WENT BEYOND STATE
REQUIREMENTS AND ADOPTED
PRINCIPLES OF POLICY CHANGES. TO
BETTER PREPARE ADVISED PROTECTED
ENSURE THE SUCCESS.
AND WELFARE OF ALL YOU SEE
STUDENT ATHLETES UNFORTUNATELY
THIS BILL STILL CREATES A
CIRCUMSTANCE WHERE ARE STILL NOW
THAT THAT YOU SEE COULD BE IN
DIRECT VIOLATION OF NC DOUBLE
THE BY LAWS AS THEY ARE
CURRENTLY WRITTEN.
I JUST TWO MONTHS AGO THE NC
DOUBLE A ANNOUNCED IT FOR
NATIONAL WORKING GROUP ON THE
ISSUE OF NAME IMAGE AND LIKENESS.
COMPOSED OF UNIVERSITY
PRESIDENTS ATHLETIC DIRECTORS
CONFERENCE COMMISSIONERS AS WELL
AS NC DOUBLE A STUDENT ATHLETES
FROM DIVISION ONE TWO AND THREE
PROGRAMS.
OF OUR REPORT IS DUE BACK TO THE
BOARD OF GOVERNORS IN OCTOBER
WITH AN UPDATE PROVIDED NEXT
MONTH IN AUGUST.
GIVEN THE SENSITIVELY PROCESS
THAT IS CURRENTLY UNDER WAY --
TO FURTHER EXPORTER YOU THE
EXTREME COMPLEXITY OF THIS ISSUE --
THE UNIVERSITY CONTINUE TO
BELIEVE THAT IT'S PREMATURE TO
PROMOTE LEGISLATION THIS AREA AT
THIS TIME -- IF CALIFORNIA WANTS
TO MAKE FUNDAMENTAL CHANGES TO
THE EXISTING LANDSCAPE OF
COLLEGIATE ATHLETICS AS WE KNOW
IT TODAY.
WE HAVE TO BE SURE THAT WE ARE
MAKING A DECISION THAT WILL NOT
HAVE ANY UNFORESEEN OR NEGATIVE
CONSEQUENCES ON STUDENT ATHLETES
IN CALIFORNIA TODAY.
IN CLOSING LET ME AGAIN NOTE
THAT YOU SEE APPRECIATE THE
ATTENTION AND CONCERN FOR
STUDENT ATHLETES BUT IT FOR THE
REASONS STATED WE HAVE TO
RESPECTFULLY COULD CONTINUE TO
BE OPPOSED -- I'M DEAL THE REST
OF MY TIME TO ANTI FEE.
DIRECTOR ATHLETICS AT LONG BEACH
STATE UNIVERSITY.
THANK YOU TYLER AND THANK
EVERYBODY FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
BE HERE TODAY.
I CURRENTLY SERVE AS THE
ATHLETIC DIRECTOR AT LONG BEACH
STATE UNIVERSITY I'M HERE TODAY
IN OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL.
NOT NECESSARILY THE CONVERSATION.
I BRIEFLY WANT TO SHARE MY
THOUGHTS THERE ARE MANY
POTENTIAL UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES -- WHICH IN THE END
COULD HARM THE VERY STUDENTS --
THAT THE AUTHOR'S INTENT TO HELP.
THERE IS A POSSIBLE SCENARIO
WITH AUTHORS WORLD WORKS AND
THERE MIGHT NOT BE ANY NEGATIVE
CONSEQUENCES.
BUT I WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK TO
SEVERAL POSSIBLE IMPACTS WHICH
WOULD LEAVE A HARSH FOOT PRINT
POSSIBLY.
THE IRST COULD BE A WORLD WHERE
CALIFORNIAN OVERSEAS ARE
RESTRICTED FROM COMPETING FOR NC
DOUBLE A CHAMPIONSHIPS.
WITH OVER TWENTY YEARS OF
EXPERIENCE WORKING IN NC DOUBLE
A I DON'T BELIEVE THE TWO WORLDS
CAN CO EXIST.
I DON'T THINK YOU CAN HAVE ONE
WORLD WHERE THE RULES SAY AXE
AND THE OTHER WORLD SAYS WHY AND
WE MEET ON THE SAME FEEL THE
COMPETITION.
I THINK THEY'RE DIAMETRICALLY
OPPOSED.
AS A MEMBER OF THE NC DOUBLE A
WERE REQUIRED. TO FOLLOW THE
RULES.
AND SHE WE KNOW OF ANY
VIOLATIONS TO SELF REPORT THOSE
RULES ARE SELF REPORT THOSE
VIOLATIONS AND BEAR THE
REPLICATIONS.
MY EXPERIENCE IS THAT SHOULD A
SCHOOL REPEATEDLY BREAK NC
DOUBLE A RULES HARSH PENALTIES
CAN FOLLOW IN EFFECT COMPETITION
SCHOLARSHIPS AND MUCH OTHER.
AN ADDITIONAL CONCERN A REAL
WORLD CONCERN FOR ME IS THE NAME
IMAGE AND LIKENESS.
WHAT ARE THE PROTECTIONS HERE?
WHAT STOP THIS DO NOT LEAVE FROM
SIGNING A DEAL WITH MGM GRAND
CASINO AND SPORTS BOOK?
SPORTS GAMBLING IS A BILLION
DOLLAR INDUSTRY AND NOW FOOTBALL
PLAYERS ARE BASKETBALL PLAYERS
MIGHT BE TEMPTED AND HAVE A
CONFLICT OF INTEREST.
WE'VE HAD A HISTORY IN NC DOUBLE
A OF POINT SHAVING SCANDALS
BEFORE NOW IS THIS AN
ENDORSEMENT TO GO OUT THERE AND
OPEN UP ANOTHER DOOR ANOTHER
PANDORA'S BOX.
THE SECOND IS CANNABIS.
CANNABIS IS THE IS A BANNED
SUBSTANCE THE NC DOUBLE A WHAT
IF A STUDENT ATHLETE SIGNED AN
ENDORSEMENT DEAL WITH.
A DISPENSARY.
WHAT IF PART OF THE -- INCENTIVE
THERE IS A REQUIREMENT TO USE
SAID.
CANNABIS THAT'S IN DIRECT
VIOLATION OF THE RULES.
AGAIN THESE ARE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES WHERE ARE THE
PROTECTIONS THAT.
PREVENT THESE THINGS FROM
HAPPENING.
THAT'S WHY I URGE.
A PAUSE THIS IS A GOOD
CONVERSATION.
IT'S THE MECHANISM THAT I
ACTUALLY OPPOSE.
IT'S IMPORTANT I'M GLAD THAT
WE'RE ALL HERE TODAY HAVING AN
OPEN CONVERSATION.
AND I WOULD URGE THAT WE TAKE A
FURTHER IN DEPTH LOOK THAT WE WE
BRING IN MORE STUDENT ATHLETES
TO BRING IN MORE COACHES WE
BRING IN MORE STAFF AND
ADMINISTRATION AND AND THE NC
DOUBLE A DOES.
BECOME MORE INVOLVED THAN I
WOULD URGE SOME TIME TO ALLOW
THE NC DOUBLE A WORKING GROUP TO
COME BACK -- YOU KNOW THE GOAL
IS TO COME BACK IN IN OCTOBER I
BELIEVE.
AND AGAIN I'M I'M NOT SURE WHAT
THE RUSHES TO GET THERE.
THESE UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES
ARE POTENTIALLY VERY REAL AND
ONCE THAT DOORS OPEN IT'S VERY
TOUGH TO GO BACK.
THE OLD ADAGE YOU KNOW OF A WOOD
WORKER YOU MEASURE TWICE AND CUT
ONCE.
LET'S NOT DO THE OPPOSITE.
THANK YOU FOR THE TIME
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OTHER WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU RUN A GIVE YOU LEVELS
WITH STANFORD UNIVERSITY IN
OPPOSITION.
ENJOY WATCHING THIS CALIFORNIA
UNIVERSE IN OPPOSITION.
ALEX GRAYS THE ASSOCIATION
INDEPENDENT CALIFORNIA COLLEGES
UNIVERSITIES IN OPPOSITION.
KATHLEEN SORRY I NOBODY
UNIVERSITY OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA IN OPPOSITION.
ANY ANY TWEETERS.
WRYNECK LANEY WITH CEOS OF
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES IN
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
ATHLETIC ASSOCIATION WE'D LIKE
TO THINK THE AUTHOR AND THE
CHAIRMAN FOR RECOGNIZING THE
DIFFERENCES BETWEEN OUR
INSTITUTIONS IN HIGH PROFILE NC
DOUBLE A PROGRAMS.
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
PARTICIPATING IN ANY DISCUSSIONS --
GOING FORWARD ON HOW BEST TO
SUPPORT OUR STUDENT ATHLETES.
THANK YOU.
JUSTIN SELLER COMBAT FOR
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
CHANCES OFFICE WE DON'T HAVE A A
POSITION ON THE BILL.
WE ARE SUPPORTIVE OF THE INTENT
BUT THE PROPOSED AMENDMENTS ARE
A BIT CONCERNING JUST BECAUSE
THE CHANCES OFFICE HAS NOT.
TRADITIONALLY HAD A ROLE IN
ATHLETICS SO THERE MAY BE SOME
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES AT OUR
AGENCY MAY NEED TO COMPLETE THE
WORK GROUP REQUIREMENTS.
THE THANK YOU.
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
YES MISTER PATTERSON.
ALRIGHT I I GOT ASKING TOUGH
QUESTIONS -- I I'M CONFLICTED
HERE -- AND I WANT.
TO ADDRESS THE QUESTION
SPECIFICALLY WITH RESPECT
RESPECT TO FRESNO STATE
UNIVERSITY I ALMA.
ALARM I REPRESENT THE UNIVERSITY
[inaudible]
IT.
FEELS LIKE WE'RE PLAYING A GAME
OF CHICKEN WITH THE NC TWO WAY
[inaudible]
AND ESTABLISHING THIS
RULE.
THAT PUTS THE STATE OUTSIDE OF
THE AND SEE TO IT I I I I I
UNDERSTAND THAT.
BUT WE ALSO HAVE AN NC TO A
SERIOUS INQUIRY INTO THIS.
SO PART OF ME SAYS I THINK WE
MADE OUR POINT.
WHAT I WANT TO ASK IS THE
IMPLEMENTATION?
WHEN DOES THIS BECOME --
ACTUALIZED.
AND IF THERE SHOULD BE -- REPORT
FROM THE NC TO WEIGH THAT IN
SOME WAYS MY MIRRORS.
BUT MAYBE DOESN'T DO EVERYTHING
THE BILL DOES.
AS THE AUTHORS WOULD WOULD WOULD
YOU BE.
COMMITTING TO STEPPING BACK.
LOOKING AT IT [inaudible]
BEFORE IMPLEMENTATION.
AND IF A NATIONAL -- NC TO A
DECISION.
WAS CLOSE ENOUGH.
COULD COULD YOU AND WOULD YOU
LIVE WITH THAT.
THROUGH THE YEAR GET ON SO THE
BILL IS DESIGNED.
DO NOT TAKE AFFECT.
UNTIL.
TWENTY TWENTY THREE AND THE
PURPOSE OF THAT.
IS FOR THE NC TWO WAY.
IF THEY CHOOSE. TO RESPOND TO
GIVE THEM THAT TIME IT ALSO IF
YOU READ THE LANGUAGE IN THE
BILL IT STATES EXPLICITLY.
THAT THE LEGISLATURE WOULD
REVISIT.
IF THE NC TWO EIGHT
SUBSTANTIALLY CHANGES THE RULES.
NOW THE OTHER THING I WANTED TO
IN FRAMING THIS IS.
IT'S IRONIC TO ME THAT WE HAVE
OUR COLLEGES HERE IN OPPOSITION.
BECAUSE THE NC TWO EIGHT IS AN
ASSOCIATION OF COLLEGES.
THESE ARE COLLEGES OPPOSING
COLLEGES.
OUR OWN COLLEGES.
HAVE THE ABILITY. TO WORK WITH
THE NC TWO WAY TO CHANGE THE
RULES.
AND IN FACT THE NC TO A HAS A
HISTORY.
OF FITS AND STARTS IN ALL
ASPECTS OF IN OUR ACTUALLY WE AS
I INDICATED I HAVE TECHNICAL
WITNESS HERE AND I WOULD LIKE TO
HAVE HIM.
PROVIDE THAT INFORMATION AND
ALSO THE LEGAL RESPONSE TO THE
ISSUE OF WHETHER THE NC TWO
EIGHT COULD.
PREVENT CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS FROM
PARTICIPATING FOR EXAMPLE AND
CHAMPIONSHIPS WOULD THAT BE
AMENABLE TO THE CHAIR.
BRIEFLY IT.
HE'S A LAWYER.
I'M IT DID IT DID THIS IS MY
PERIOD TO THE QUESTION YES I
WOULD MUCH RATHER HEAR FROM THE
AUTHOR SPECIFICALLY AND DIRECTLY.
AND NOT AND NOT A LAWYER'S AYE
AYE.
QUESTION IS.
IT IS VERY VERY YES EXPLICIT YES
IF IF IF YOU IF THIS.
BILL MOVES.
BECAUSE THEY MOVED THE BALL.
AND NC TO A DOZEN FACT COME BACK
WITH SOMETHING.
REASONABLY ACCEPTABLE PRIOR --
TO THE BILL BECOMING --
EFFECTIVE RIGHT SO IT'S NOT EASY
YOU ARE ARE YOU COMMITTING.
AS AUTHORS HERE AND NOW.
THAT THAT SET OF CIRCUMSTANCES
WOULD CAUSE YOU TO IN FACT
REVISIT THE BILL.
AND PRESENT WASTE WHERE WE ARE
NOT IN CONFLICT IN CONFLICT.
THE VERY.
ABSOLUTELY IN THE VERY WARM.
THE VERY WAY THE BILL IS WRITTEN
MAKES THAT COMMITMENT.
THE VERY WAY THE BILL AS WRITTEN
IF YOU LOOK AT THE VERY LANGUAGE
THAT WE'RE PUTTING INTO STATUTE
IT MAKES THAT COMMITMENT.
AND BUT THE REASON I FEEL THAT
THE BILL IS STILL NECESSARY EVEN
WITH THE THREE YEAR DELAY.
IS THE ANC TO A COMMISSIONED
THEIR OWN THIS IS NOT THE FIRST
TASK FORCE THEY'VE HAD ON SUCH A
SUBJECT.
THEY ASKED CONDOLEEZZA RICE
WHICH YOU KNOW HAS AN
AFFILIATION WITH THE NFL TO SET
UP A COMMISSION. TO LOOK EXACTLY
AT THESE ISSUES IN RESPONSE TO
THE VARIOUS LAWSUITS THAT THEY
HAD EXPERIENCED THE O'BANNON
LAWSUIT VARIOUS OTHERS.
AND THEY SET UP THE CONDOLEEZZA
RICE COMMISSION.
THAT COMMISSION.
RECOMMENDED THAT IN SITU A
CHANGE THE RULES IN RECOMMENDED
THAT STUDENTS HAVE THE RIGHT TO
THEIR OWN IMAGE AND LIKENESS THE
NC TWO EIGHT JUST DIDN'T EVEN
WRITE REFERENCE BACK THEY NEVER
SAID WELL.
WE ACCEPT THESE RECOMMENDATIONS
FOR KNOCKING ACT THE JUST.
THEY NEVER RESPONDED THAT WAS
ONLY LAST OCTOBER OR A YEAR AGO
SO.
SO AND I COULD CITE MANY
ADDITIONAL INCIDENTS WHERE NC.
TO EIGHT CHANGE THE RULES A
LITTLE OR JUST IGNORED EVEN.
TASK FORCES AND COMMISSIONS THAT
THEY THEMSELVES SET UP.
AND WE WANT TO LOOK AT SOME OF
THE THE UNFAIRNESS OF THIS.
TENNIS PLAYERS FOR EXAMPLE IN
THE UNDER THE NC TWO EIGHT ARE
ALLOWED TO TAKE HOME A TEN
THOUSAND DOLLAR PURSE EACH YEAR
[inaudible]
NO OTHER.
ATHLETE IS.
EVEN THOUGH YOU MIGHT HAVE A
WRESTLER FOR IT THANK.
OR ANY OTHER STUDENT ATHLETES
WHO MIGHT HAVE A SIMILAR ABILITY --
TO PARTICIPATE IN A TOURNAMENT
THAT GIVES A CASH AWARD BUT ONLY.
THE TENNIS PLAYERS.
D. BASKETBALL PLAYERS RECENTLY
MEN BASKETBALL PLAYERS THE NC TO
A IS NOW ALLOWING TO HAVE AN
AGENT.
ONLY MEANT WHAT HAPPENED A TITLE.
NINE SO WE SEE THE NC TWO WAY
WHEN THEY GET UNDER PRESSURE
MAKE A LITTLE CHANGE.
LET'S SEE IF THEY'RE SERIOUS IN
THERE WILL MAKE A SUBSTANTIAL
CHANGE.
BUT FINALLY THE THREAT REGARDING.
THAT WE WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO
PLAY IN CHAMPIONSHIPS.
THE I WILL SPEAK FOR MY
TECHNICAL EXPERT BUT MIGHT THE
TECHNICAL EXPERT THAT I HAVE
THAT THE TABLE.
IS -- APOLOGIES FOR MY PAPER SIR
FLOATING.
OCT SKEWS ME MARC ALMOND WHO IS
IN NEW YORK LAW PROFESSOR AND
THE AUTHOR OF THE FORBES ARTICLE
WHY THE NC TO A LIKELY CANNOT
KEEP CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS. FOR ME
THEIR CHAMPIONSHIPS OR FROM
GIVING THIS RIGHT BECAUSE IT
WOULD BE AN ANTI TRUST VIOLATION.
AND THIS IS WHY NOW YOU SEE THE
NC TO A HAS NOT THREATENED TO
ELIMINATE CALIFORNIA COLLEGES
FROM ANY PARTICIPATION ONLY FROM
CHAMPIONSHIPS BECAUSE IT'S THAT
IF YOU'RE A COLLEGE ATHLETE.
TO THINK THAT YOU WOULD NOT BE
ABLE TO PLACE CHAMPIONSHIPS IS
QUITE IT YOU KNOW THAT.
THERE REALLY WOULD BE WORRISOME
TO A STUDENT BUT THEY MADE THAT
SORT OF MOST POTENT THREAT.
BUT THEY DON'T REALLY HAVE THE
LEGAL ABILITY TO DO SO BECAUSE
IT WOULD BE AN ANTITRUST
VIOLATION AND I WOULD REFER YOU
TO THAT ARTICLE INTO A NUMBER OF
OTHER ARTICLES NOW THAT HAVE
BEEN WRITTEN BY LIKE TO ASK THE
REPRESENT A FOR THE C..
CSU -- WHAT WHAT'S WHAT'S THE
BIG DEAL?
IF WE HAVE A BILL THAT IS NOT
GOING TO GO INTO EFFECT. FOR
THREE YEARS [inaudible]
AND WE CURRENTLY HAVE A PROCESS
BY THE NC TWO WAY. TO TAKE A A A
A GOOD AND SERIOUS.
LOOK AT THIS OP I'M FINDING IT
DIFFICULT TO BE SYMPATHETIC.
ARE OVER -- SORT OF THIS
DOOMSDAY.
CLAIM HERE BUT IT IS OF CONCERN
TO ME IF.
IT TURNS OUT TO BE REAL.
SO IT IT IN AND CORRECT ME IF
I'M WRONG IT SEEMS.
THAT NOTHING WILL HAPPEN OVER A
THREE YEAR PERIOD OF TIME EXCEPT
WE WILL BE ABLE TO SEE.
HOW SERIOUS THE NC TO A
[inaudible]
IS ABOUT [inaudible]
FIXING THIS.
YES I'M PLEASE.
THERE IS AND IT'S A LITTLE BIT
OF THE WEEDS IN MY NEW **** BUT
IT'S ALREADY HAPPENING IT'S
CALLED NEGATIVE RECRUITING SO
WHAT COLLEGES ARE DOING -- AT
THE COLLEGE LEVEL YOU RECRUITED
THE HIGH SCHOOL LEVEL SO THAT
THE CLASS OF TWENTY TWENTY THREE
ARE ALREADY BEING CONTACTED. TO
BE RECOVERABLE PROSPECTIVE
STUDENT ATHLETES SO WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT THOSE YOUNG MEN
AND WOMEN WHO WOULD BE AFFECTED
BY THIS RULE.
AND THE NEGATIVE RECRUITING
COMES FROM COACHES AND WE'VE
ALREADY SEEN IT OR COACHES
OUTSIDE THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
ARE USING IT AGAINST SCHOOLS
LIKE LONG BEACH STATE.
STANFORD AS THE GO DOWN THE LIST
WHERE THEY SAY.
WELL YOU YOU TO VERBALLY COMMIT
TO US WHAT I'M NOT GONNA HAVE A
SCHOLARSHIP IN YOU KNOW AND SEE
IS NOT GOING TO ALLOW YOU
[inaudible] TO PLAY.
AGAIN WITH TWO WORLDS.
THERE'S NO WAY FOR EXAMPLE IF
REGGIE BUSH RIGHT NOW IS BEING
RECRUITED. TO PLAY FOOTBALL AT
TEXAS OR USC.
AND HE WENT TO TEXAS IN THE SHOW
TO MOST OF THE GREAT GREAT GREAT.
HE GOES AS SEE IT'S GOOD IT'S
GOOD IT'S GREAT -- AND BY THE
WAY WE CAN WE CAN GET YOU A
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS YOU
KNOW ENDORSING TOYOTA.
EVERY TIME REGGIE BUSH IS GONNA
GO TO USC THOSE OUTSIDE SCHOOLS
ARE NEVER GOING TO ALLOW IT
THERE'S THIRTEEN HUNDREDS --
SCHOOLS THAT MAKE UP THE NC
DOUBLE WAY CALIFORNIA IS THE
DROP IN THE BUCKET IN TERMS OF
THE MEMBERSHIP.
SO TO TO TO SAY THAT CALIFORNIA
IS OF THIS EIGHT HUNDRED POUND
GORILLA THAT JUST GONNA BURY ITS
WAY THROUGH AND PUSH PEOPLE
AROUND -- THAT'S NOT THE CASE I
I WILL I WISH IT WAS.
YOU KNOW PERSONALLY I THINK IT
IF THAT WERE THE CASE WHY DO WE
KEEP ADDING MORE AND MORE STATES
TO THE BAND TRAVEL LIST.
AND WE HAVE TO DEAL WITH THAT
NOW WE WE CAN'T CONTRACT GAMES
WITH CERTAIN STATES BECAUSE
WE'RE NOT ALLOWED TO TRAVEL
THERE.
SO IF WE WERE THESE LEADERS AND
I WISH WE WERE I I WISH WE WERE
I BELIEVE IN IT I BELIEVE.
THAT THE STATES ARE PASSING
DISCRIMINATORY LAWS.
BUT IT DOES AFFECT WHAT WE DO
HERE SO.
THERE ARE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES IN THIS THREE YEAR
PERIOD WHERE YOU WILL SEE A
FLIGHT OF TALENTS YOU COULD SEE
COACHES LEAVE AM I GONNA HAVE A
JOB I'VE GOT A FAMILY TO FEED
WHAT IF NEVADA THERE'S A SYSTEM
COACHING JOB IN.
WELL I DON'T KNOW IF I'M GONNA
HAVE A JOB IN [inaudible]
TWENTY TWENTY THREE IS THAT.
A CERTAIN THING NOW IT IT'S NOT
BUT PEOPLE HAVE TO MAKE
DECISIONS AND YOUR FORCING
REALLY YOUNG MEN AND WOMEN IN
HIGH SCHOOL TO MAKE DECISIONS
AND FAMILIES TO MAKE DECISIONS
RIGHT NOW.
WHY ARE WE FORCING THAT TO
HAPPEN?
I I MEAN LET'S JUST TAKE A PAUSE
HERE LET'S LET'S SEE WHAT COMES
BACK AND AT WERE READY TO TO TO
TAKE FURTHER ACTION AND WE TAKE
FURTHER ACTION BUT AGAIN.
MEASURE TWICE CUT ONCE.
MISTER AND APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE QUESTION I I
MUST TELL YOU THAT I I AM
SYMPATHETIC BUT I ALSO.
ABOUT A PLACE HERE WHERE I I I
NEED TO HAVE FURTHER
CONVERSATIONS WITH RESIDENTS
THAT UNIVERSITY OVER THIS THESE
THESE THESE CONFLICTS
[inaudible]
OUR SERIOUS. TWO PEOPLE I KNOW
WELL WHO ARE STUDENTS AND WHO
ARE WHO MAY BE FACING THIS.
SO I'M NOT I'M GONNA BE I'M NOT
GOING TO BE CASTING A VOTE TODAY
BUT I WANT TO RESERVE MY VOTE
FOR THE FLOOR.
AND WHEN IT GETS TO THE FLOOR
WILL HAVE SOME DISCUSSIONS.
UP PRIOR TO THAT WITH WITH
RESIDENTS STATE.
THAT TO REALLY DIG INTO THE
REALITY OF WHETHER OR NOT FRESNO
STATE IS EXPERIENCING THIS KIND
OF RECRUITMENT FLIGHT AS A
RESULT -- AND IT'S NOT JUST
GOING TO BE WITH THE EXECUTIVES --
IT'S GOING TO BE WAS STUDENTS
AND ATHLETES AND FAMILIES I KNOW
VERY VERY WELL SO I I APPRECIATE
THE EFFORT.
I BUT I'M TROUBLED ABOUT WHAT I
DON'T KNOW AND I'VE I'VE GOT THE
FIRM THAT UP BEFORE I CAN CAST
AND I MR LIVING.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIRMAN THANK YOU -- TO THE
AUTHORS FOR PRESENTING THIS
BOMBING OF A FOR IT TODAY I
THINK THAT THERE ARE A LOT OF
ISSUES THAT STILL NEED TO BE
WORKED OUT I I KNOW THAT YOU'VE
GOT DELAYED IMPLEMENTATION -- HI
HEAR AND UNDERSTAND THE CONCERNS
OF THE OPPOSITION BUT THIS IS A
IS.
AN ISSUE THAT I REMEMBER PEOPLE
ON MY CAMPUS TALKING TO ME ABOUT
BACK WHEN I WAS A STUDENT BACK
IN THE LAST MILLENNIUM.
I GUESS I'M TRYING TO MAKE
MYSELF SOUND TOO OLD BUT I MEAN
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN TALKING ABOUT
THIS FOR A LONG TIME.
AND AND CA IS GONNA MOVE AS SLOW
AS IT WANTS TO MOVE.
AND AND IN IN A WAY THAT IS.
UNEQUAL AS YOU'VE ALREADY
DEMONSTRATED IN IN THE EXAMPLES
THAT YOU'VE GIVEN AND THINGS
THAT THEY'VE ALREADY ALLOWED --
SO WHETHER THIS BILL ACTUALLY
BECOMES LAW -- IS IS ALMOST
SECONDARY TO TE FACT THAT WE
NEED TO COAX THIS CONVERSATION
FURTHER THAN IT'S EVER BEEN
BEFORE IN YOUR BILL CERTAINLY IS
A VEHICLE FOR THAT THANK YOU
[inaudible]
MR GABRIEL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR -- SO IT
JUST SOME QUESTIONS FOR FOR THE
OPPOSITION IN PARTICULAR FOR THE
UC SYSTEM.
I CAN UNDERSTAND THE THE
CHALLENGES YOU FACE AN ARGUMENT
ABOUT GETTING CAUGHT IN BETWEEN
THE YOU KNOW PER PERSON REALLY
CALIFORNIA STATE LAW AND NC
DOUBLE A BY LAWS.
THE QUESTION I HAVE IS WHAT'S
THE WHAT'S UNIVERSITIES POSITION
ON THE CAR ROLE.
THE COROLLA OF WHAT THE CURRENT
RULE I'M SORRY -- THE GUARD RULE
TO NAY MAYBE TO LIKE THIS YEAH I
KNOW SO I I I UNDERSTAND.
THAT AGAIN WE KIND OF WENT AND
TALKED ABOUT HOW WE'RE NOT
OPPOSED TO THE CONVERSATION THAT
WE'RE HAVING TODAY I THINK IT'S
ONE THAT NEEDS TO BE HAPPENED I
THINK THE BILL.
CERTAINLY SERVE THAT PURPOSE I
CAN'T SAYING GO ON A LIMB AND
SAY WHAT THE UNIVERSE MUSICIAN
BECAUSE I MOSTLY CHANNELING.
THE CONCERNS FROM ALL THE
DIFFERENT ATHLETIC DIRECTOR
SMALL THE CAMPUSES SO I CAN'T GO
ON A LIMB AND SAY THAT BUT I DO
THINK.
THERE IS INTEREST IN THIS ISSUE
AND I THINK -- YOU KNOW WE NEED
TO TALK ABOUT IT MORE THAT'S
KIND OF WHY MY TEST MY SUGGESTS
THAT WE WAIT TO SEE I GET THAT
IT'S AN UNSTABLE A WORKING GROUP
BUT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT.
A WORKING GROUP THAT'S GOING TO
HAVE YOU KNOW PRESIDENT OF THE
BIGGEST UNIVERSITIES EIGHTIES
FROM THE SMALLEST UNIVERSITIES
DO NAPPIES FROM THE THREE AND D.
TO ANTI.
ONE AND THEN WE CAN LOOK AT IT
AS A STATE AND SAY WHAT DOES
THIS SAY WHAT IT WHAT DOES IT
MEAN YOU KNOW WE DON'T KNOW WE
DON'T KNOW AND THAT'S THAT'S
PART OF OUR FEARS THAT.
WE JUST DON'T KNOW WHAT THIS
LOOKS LIKE AND WHAT THE
POTENTIAL.
YOU KNOW FABRICA POLICE ATHLETIC
TO LOOK LIKE PASSED TWENTY
TWENTY THREE WHATEVER THE BILL
GETS INTO IMPLEMENTATION SO.
I HOPE THAT AS YOUR QUESTION BUT
I THINK THE CONCERN AGAIN IS
THAT WERE KIND OF BEEN STUCK IN
THE MIDDLE THIS WHOLE PROCESS
AND WE'VE BEEN TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT A WAY -- TO YOU KNOW MOVE
FOR IN A PRODUCTIVE MANNER BUT
IT JUST JUST HASN'T HAPPENED YET.
THANK YOU FOR THAT I I WILL SAY
AS A AS A AS A PROUD CAL LAMANNA
IN A BIG CAL FOOTBALL FAN AND
AND SOMEONE WHO CARES A LOT
ABOUT.
THE CSU SYSTEM IS PROUD TO
PRESENT REPRESENTS THE SUN --
YOU KNOW I WISH THAT THE THE THE
CSU AND YOU SEE WOULD BE MORE.
OUT FRONT ON THIS ISSUE I THINK
THAT THE SYSTEM THAT CURRENTLY
EXISTS IS DEEPLY EXPLICATE F.
AND I THINK IT WOULD WRECK
REFLECT REALLY REALLY WELL.
ON BOTH OF THOSE SYSTEMS AS
MEMBER INSTITUTIONS OF THE NC
DOUBLE A TO SAY LISTEN WE THINK
THAT THE CURRENT SYSTEM WE HAVE
ISN'T FAIR AND TREATS ATHLETES
ON FAIRLY AND THAT WE WANT TO BE
PART OF MAKING POSITIVE CHANGE
SO.
I CERTAINLY APPRECIATE THAT
THERE ARE AS AS THE WITNESS FROM
LONG BEACH THEY POINT OUT SOME
POTENTIAL DOWNSIDES TO THIS
THERE CERTAINLY A LOT THAT WE
DON'T KNOW I UNDERSTAND THOSE
CONFLICTS BUT I HAVE TO WEIGH.
THOSE POTENTIAL DOWNSIDES WHICH
ARE UNKNOWN POTENTIAL CONFLICTS
IN THE FUTURE WITH THE DOWNSIDE
TO THE CURRENT SYSTEM AND THE
CURRENT SYSTEM AS I SAID I THINK
IS DEEPLY EXPLICATED -- IT'S
PARTICULAR EXPLOITATIVE OF
PEOPLE OF COLOR AND I THINK IT'S
VERY APPROPRIATE FOR CALIFORNIA
TO WEIGH IN HERE TO WEIGH IN
WITH OUR VALUES TO TRY PUSHING
CHANGE I COMMEND THE AUTHORS FOR
THE SYSTEM THAT THEY'VE SET UP
THEY'VE DELAYED THE
IMPLEMENTATION. FOR A LONG TIME
SO WE CAN SEE THEY REALLY GIVEN
THE NC DOUBLE A TIME TO WORK
THIS OUT WE HAVE A LOT OF
OPPORTUNITIES TO SEE THAT.
OUR PROCESS COME TO FRUITION IF
IT IF THE IF THE NC DOUBLE A
DOES THE RIGHT THING -- THEN WE
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO CHANGE
CALIFORNIA LAW TO CONFORM
WITHOUT TO RECOGNIZE THAT BUT IT
APPROPRIATELY PLACES A TIME LINE
ON THAT AND MAKE SURE THAT THEY
KNOW THE CALIFORNIA'S GOING.
TO IS GOING TO LEAD WITH ITS
VALUES AND SO I WOULD REALLY --
AS SOMEBODY WHO CARES A LOT
ABOUT.
THESE PUBLIC UNIVERSITY SYSTEMS
WHO CARES A LOT ABOUT ATHLETICS
AT THOSE SYSTEM -- I REALLY
ENCOURAGE YOU TO HAVE A A FREE
CONVERSATION WITH YOUR MEMBERS
AND TO SAY LISTEN WE WE FEEL
THAT IT'S IMPORTANT.
AS INSTITUTIONS THAT ARE
COMMITTED TO THE PUBLIC GOOD
THAT REFLECT THE VALUES THE
PEOPLE THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
WE HAD A LEAD ON THESE ISSUES
AND SO I WOULD ENCOURAGE YOU TO
DO THAT -- COMMEND THE AUTHORS
FOR THIS IMPORTANT MEASURE LOOK
FOR TO VOTING FOR TODAY THANK
YOU.
MISTER KILEY.
A GOOD AFTERNOON THAT CAN I JUST
GET OUT A LITTLE BETTER SENSE OF
WHAT KIND OF ENDORSEMENTS YOU
THINK WILL BE -- DEALING WITH I
MEAN I YOU MENTIONED -- SENATOR
SKINNER AYE YOU KNOW YOU COULD
HAVE LOCAL ALREADY CAUGHT ROTARY
CLUBS THEY'RE PROVIDING SUPPORT
BUT IMAGINE THAT'LL BE PRETTY
SMALL SLICE OF THE OVERALL.
REVENUES OR WE'D YOU KNOW IT'S
GONNA BE VIDEO GAMES CHIU DEALS
ATHLETES STARRING KOMMER WHO ARE
KIND OF THE BIG POTS OF REVENUE
THAT YOU THINK WATCHING
MATERIALIZE -- THANK YOU SO
MEMBER KILEY -- THE THERE'S ONLY
JUST AS WE SEE ONLY A HANDFUL OF
ATHLETES ACTUALLY GET TO GO PRO
THERE'S ONLY A HANDFUL OF
ATHLETES THAT WILL GET.
SIGNIFICANT MONEY FROM AN
ENDORSEMENT DEAL OR YOU KNOW
WHAT CHIU OR OF VIDEO GAME.
IN FACT THE VAST MAJORITY OF
ATHLETES AND THEY COULD BE OF
ANY ANY TYPE OF ANY SPORT.
WHAT THIS REALLY JUST GIVES THEM
THE ABILITY DO IS MARKET
THEMSELVES?
SO RIGHT NOW WE SEE COLLEGE
STUDENTS AND WE SEE RICHEST
EVERYBODY EVERYBODY HAS THE
ABILITY TO USE SOCIAL MEDIA
WHETHER IT'S YOU TUBE INSTAGRAM
HOWEVER.
TO THEY CAN MONETIZE SO YOU HAD --
A GENTLEMAN AT CAL MY SAID LIKE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GABRIEL I'M A
BEAR -- WILLIAM HAN.
WAS APOLOGIES MISTER HAN IF YOU
HEAR THIS BUT HE WAS WITHOUT
TALENT OKAY HE WAS HE LIKE TO
SING.
AND HE WOULD STAND ON SPRAWL AND
SEEING TERRIBLY BUT YOU TO
THEMSELF AND MADE.
LIKE A LOT OF MONEY HE MONETIZED
HIS YOU TUBE THERE WAS NOTHING
THAT PREVENTED HIM FROM DOING SO
NOW IF I TAKE.
CAITLYN -- HASHI THE INCREDIBLE
GYMNAST AT UCLA SHE HAS SEVENTY
TWO MILLION YOUTUBE VIEWERS
SEVENTY TWO MILLION.
SHE COULD MONETIZE THAT.
SHE'S NOT ALLOWED.
TO WILL SHE HAVE THE ABILITY TO
BE PAID PROFESSIONALLY.
PRETTY DOUBTFUL MAYBE NOT MUCH --
ANYWAY THAT TIME IN COLLEGE MAY
HAVE BEEN THE REAL TIME THAT SHE
WOULD HAVE BEEN ABLE.
TO RECOVER ANY TYPE OF
COMPENSATION FOR THE INCREDIBLE
TALENT SHE HAD.
SO THE NAME IMAGE AND LIKENESS
IS NOT RESTRICTED JUST TO AN
EXTERNAL ENTITY GIVING YOU A
ENDORSEMENT IT COULD BE JUST YOU
MARKETING.
T. SHIRTS OF YOURSELF HATS.
YEAH IF WITH YOUR PERMISSION
CLASS FROM THE THIS THE FORMER
OF ALL UP WHERE FOR STANFORD SHE
STILL HERE I SORRY TO MAKE YOU
HAVE TO COME BACK OUT BUT YOU
HAD MENTIONED YOU HAD
ENDORSEMENT DEALS THAT WHAT KIND
OF THAT.
IMPORTANT TO YOU OFFER.
YOU MAY.
I'M SO YEAH I MEAN WE'RE IT
SUMMED FOR SOME PEOPLE IT COULD
BE REALLY AND BIG ENDORSEMENTS
BUT ON ON MY END I WAS TRAINING
WITH THE U. S. NATIONAL TEAM
DURING HIGH SCHOOL AND HAD LIKE
I COULD HAVE BEEN MAKING A
WEEKLY STIPEND.
AND DID NOT TAKE IT BECAUSE I
WAS NOT ONLY BE AND SO I WAS NOT
PROTECTED BY THOSE RULES AND I
WAS TRYING TO REMAIN ELIGIBLE
FOR MY AND SEE A CAREER THAT I
WAS NOT YET.
EVEN -- PARTICIPATING IN AND SO
THE NCAA RULES READ BACK ALL THE
WAY TO HIGH SCHOOLERS AND I
PLAYED BEACH VOLLEYBALL AS WELL
SO I WAS TALKING WITH TWO SPORT
ATHLETE I AM IN THE NCAA AND
DURING MY TIME IN HIGH SCHOOL --
I WAS APPROACHED FOR YOU KNOW
SMALL SUNGLASSES DEALS BUT GOOD
SUNGLASSES THAT PROTECT YOUR
EYES ARE LIKE TWO HUNDRED
DOLLARS AND A PAIR FREE
SUNGLASSES WOULD HAVE MADE A
DIFFERENCE YOU KNOW AND AND THEN
THERE WAS ALSO A TV SHOW THAT
THEY WANTED TO DO.
WAS LIKE SOME STRANGE MTV
REALITY SHOW -- AND I DIDN'T
WANT TO GET INTO MUDDY WATERS
WITHOUT HAVING REPRESENTATION
BUT AT THAT AGE YOU'RE TONIGHT
AN AGENT -- AND SO REGARDLESS OF
WHETHER OR NOT I WOULD HAVE DONE
THE TV SHOW THE POINT WAS I
DIDN'T EVEN HAVE A RIGHT TO AN
AGENT -- AND SO. FOR SOME PEOPLE
THIS COULD BE AS SIMPLE AS
GETTING A FREE MEAL EVERY ONCE
IN AWHILE FROM A WELL MEANING
FAN -- AND FOR OTHERS IT COULD
MEAN A LOT MORE -- BUT IT'S
REALLY JUST THE RIGHT TO HAVING
THE ABILITY TO MARKET YOURSELF I
KNOW IT'S PRETTY COMMON FOR
OTHER VITAL PLAYERS OF YOUR
CALIBER TO RECEIVE SIMILAR
OFFERS.
YOUR PARENTS I WOULD SAY SO
WOMEN'S LEVELS IMMENSELY POPULAR
AND I REALLY THINK THAT WERE
BEING DENIED A MARKET AT THE END
CA LEVEL -- YOU HAVE GIRLS THAT
WE ARE WE AT LEAST MY FRESHMAN
YEAR I KNOW THAT WE BROKE EVEN
IN THE ATHLETIC DEPARTMENT
PLEASE THAT'S WHAT I WAS TOLD
LIKE WE WERE NOT.
WE WERE BRING IN ENOUGH REVENUE
FOR THE SCHOOL THAT WE WERE NOT
LOSING MONEY FOR THE SCHOOL AND
THAT I I THINK.
COULD WE COULD BE MAKING EVEN
MORE MONEY BOTH FOR THE
UNIVERSITIES AND FOR OURSELVES
IF WE WERE GIVEN THE CHANCE TO
MARKET OURSELVES.
ESPECIALLY IN THE AGE OF SOCIAL
MEDIA.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- DID YOU
WANT TO FOLLOW UP ON THAT I JUST
WANT TO MENTION.
THERE IS THE CONCEPT AGAIN OF
AMATEURISM.
AND PROFESSIONALISM THERE ARE
OPTIONS ONE EXAMPLE WOULD BE
TIGER WOODS.
HE DECIDED TO GO TO STANFORD HE
FOR AGO HE FOR EAGLE ABOUT
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS BECAUSE HE
DECIDED THAT HE WANTED GO TO
COLLEGE.
HE WANTED TO BE AN AMATEUR.
HE DID HAVE THE OPTION TO TURN
PRO AND MAKE MONEY.
AND TODAY WITH DISTANCE LEARNING
YOU CAN STILL GO TO SCHOOL
THERE'S VERY OPTIONS WE SEE MANY
STUDENT ATHLETES TO EXASCALE TO
BE FINISHED UP THE CAREER TAKING.
ONLINE COURSEWORK SO YOU KNOW I
WENT THROUGH THE LIST OF ALL OF
OUR SPORTS.
AND IF MONEY WAS THE ISSUE.
YOU'RE NOT PROHIBITED FROM
MAKING MONEY YOU CAN GO ON THE
LPGA.
THE PGA.
THERE'S WATER POLO VOLLEYBALL
THERE'S A V. P. THE I MEAN YOU
GO DOWN THE LIST SO IF YOU WANT
TO MONETIZE YOURSELF IF YOU'RE
GOOD ENOUGH.
YOU CAN GO MAKE MONEY THERE
THERE'S NOT A RESTRICTION ON
MAKING MONEY IN AMERICA AND
BEING AN ATHLETE.
BUT THERE IS A RESTRICTION NOW
IN TERMS OF THE NC DOUBLE A
RULES AND THAT'S THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN AMATEURISM AND BEING A
PROFESSIONAL.
THANK YOU AND JUST ONE MORE
QUESTION LET ME GO AHEAD OF YOU --
DID YOU THINK THERE'S ANY
ARRESTS THAT -- THIS MIGHT --
ADVANTAGED SCHOOLS AND LARGE
MEDIA MARKETS WHERE -- YOU KNOW
THEY'LL BE A GREATER ABILITY TO
MONETIZE -- YOUR LIKENESS SO
THAT YOU KNOW MAYBE IF YOU'RE A
SCHOOL IN LA YOU'D BE A
ADVANTAGE OVER SCHOOL FROM A
SMALLER MARKET.
I I I MORE THAN LIKELY BUT I I
DON'T AGAIN I DON'T THINK IT'S
ABOUT -- WHAT MARKET IT'S THE
VALUE THAT?
I INDIVIDUAL OR COMPANY OR LOCAL
BUSINESSES FIND AND THAT
ATHLETES LIKE YOU SAY COULD BE A
HOME TOWN KID THAT GREW UP IN.
BY CELAYA AND THE LOCAL CAR
DEALERSHIPS HAVE LET THIS KID I
WANT TO PUT ITS POSTER MY ONE
BILL AND I WANNA PANEL FOR THAT
I WANT I WANT TO USE HIS IMAGE
HOPEFULLY HE'LL SELL PARTS OF
OUR OUR OUR FROM OUR LOCAL
COMMUNITY I MEAN.
WE'RE SAYING TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
REGARD TO WHAT MARKET YOUR HEAD
AND WE'RE TRYING TO MAKE IT AND
MAKE PEOPLE UNDERSTAND THIS IS
NOT ABOUT MAKING MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS WOULD NOT WE I MEAN VERY
FEW ATHLETES WILL FALL INTO THAT
CATEGORY AND THOSE WHO DO.
USUALLY LEAVE SCHOOL EARLY AGAIN
AS I ON WILLIAMSON'S OF THE
WORLD BUT THE MAJORITY OF I'M
GONNA STAY FOR FOUR YEARS AND
WHILE THEY'RE THERE PLAYING
PLAYING.
BASKETBALL LIKE ED O'BANNON GET
FOR FOUR YEARS YOU WOULD HOPE
THAT.
ONCE YOU TURN ON A VIDEO GAME
YOU FIND YOUR LIKENESS ON THE
VIDEO GAME YOU SHOULD HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO BENEFIT FROM IT AND
THAT'S ALL WE'RE SAYING IF
YOU'RE GONNA USE SOMEONE'S.
NAME IMAGE AND LIKENESS LET THAT
APTLY CONTROL THAT.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WEBER.
THANK YOU I WANT TO THANK -- THE
COLLEAGUES WHO COME IN AND
OBVIOUSLY FRAME THIS MESSAGE FOR
US -- YOU KNOW I'M I WAS READING.
IN ONE OF THE ARTICLES -- THAT
IF WE PASS THIS BILL THAT OUR
STUDENTS WOULD BE BANNED FROM
PLAYING IN ANY KIND OF
TOURNAMENT BY IN SITU A IS THAT
CORRECT.
ARE YOU WOULD TRY TO DO THAT.
I MAY YES PLEASE POTENTIALLY THE
THREATS THERE POTENTIALLY YES IS
IT A GUARANTEED NO BUT
POTENTIALLY YES I HOPE NOT YOU
KNOW CALIFORNIA THAT LIKE RENTS
SO THAT MAKES THIS A VERY UNIQUE
STATEMENT SENSE.
BY IT ALL OUT YES PLEASE ONLY.
GIVEN THAT THE OPPOSITION WAS
ABLE TO ANSWER THAT QUESTION CAN
THAT.
OVER TECHNICAL EXPERTS.
DOCTOR WEBER YES PLEASE OKAY.
HI THANK YOU I'M MARC EDELMAN I
AM A PROFESSOR OF LAW WITH
TENURE AT THE CITY UNIVERSITY OF
NEW YORK IS A CLEAN SCHOOL OF
BUSINESS.
I'VE ALSO BEEN ON FACULTY FOR
MORE THAN TEN YEARS AS AN
ADJUNCT AT FORDHAM LAW SCHOOL.
AND THE FORBES PIECE THAT I
WROTE I WAS A MICROCOSM OF OVER
TWENTY LAW REVIEW ARTICLES I'VE
WRITTEN AND PUBLISHED ON ANTI
TRUST AND THE NC DOUBLE I MY
POSITION AS WELL THE NC DOUBLE A
HAS INDEED.
MADE THE THREAT THE BAND SCHOOLS
THAT ALLOW ATHLETES TO SIGN DOOR
SMITH DEALS.
ARE MUCH AS IT'S CORRECT.
THAT A COLLEGE AT THE FALL THE
NC DOUBLE A IS RULES THE NC
DOUBLE A ALSO HAVE TO FOLLOW THE
LAW OF THE LAND AND THAT
INCLUDES SECTION ONE OF THE
SHERMAN ACT.
WHICH IS ANTI TRUST LAW.
THE NC DOUBLE A IS MADE UP OF
MORE THAN TWELVE HUNDRED MEMBER
SCHOOLS WHICH GIVES THEM A
MONOPOLY OVER COLLEGE ATHLETICS.
WHEN THESE TWELVE HUNDRED MEMBER
SCHOOLS COME TOGETHER AND PASS A
RULE THAT SAYS NO MEMBER SCHOOL
MAY COMPENSATE OR ALLOW ANY
ATHLETE THE COULD MAKE MONEY?
ON THEIR OWN NAME AND LIKENESS
THAT WOULD AMOUNT TO WHAT'S
CONSIDERED BOTH WAGE FIXING AND
A GROUP BOYCOTT ALTERNATIVELY
KNOWN AS A CONCERTED REFUSAL TO
DEAL.
BOTH WOULD BE PROBLEMATIC UNDER
SECTION ONE OF THE SHERMAN ACT.
TWO RECENT CASES THE JENKINS
CASE IN THE BANNING CASE PAUL
FROM THE NINTH CIRCUIT.
AS WELL AS THE SUPREME COURT
DECISION IN NC DOUBLE A VERSE
BOARD OF REGENTS.
HOLD AT THE NC DOUBLE A IS
INDEED SUBJECT TO ANTITRUST LAW.
AND IT'S MY OPINION THAT FAR
MORE LIKELY THAN NOT IF THEY
ENACTED THIS RESTRAINT IT WOULD
DEEM TO BE ILLEGAL UNDER OUR
ANTI TRUST LAWS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- MR OF
CONTORT MY SENATOR HERE FROM
FROM LOS ANGELES OF YOU ARE YOU
SAY THIS IS NOT REALLY AN ISSUE
OF MAKING MILLIONS.
BUT IT REALLY IS IT'S JUST WHO'S
GETTING -- MILLION WALLS BILLION
FOR THEM.
THAT'S WHAT I'D LIKE TO SAY THAT
THIS IS A BIG BIG MONEY.
AND WE SEEM RULES THAT HAVE
CHANGED IN ORDER TO GET BIG
MONEY.
I MEAN THE FACT THAT WE ARE A
DEMANDING THAT DOGS STUDENTS
CAN'T PLAY STRAIGHT OUT OF HIGH
SCHOOL IN CERTAIN SPORTS
PARTICULARLY.
OF IS ONCE AGAIN NOT ABOUT THE
NEED OF THE STUDENTS REALLY
ABOUT THE NEED OF THE SPORT IN
ORDER TO KEEP THESE FOLKS THESE
CAMPUSES COMPETITIVE I GATHER.
THAT'S THERE AND YOU KNOW HAVING
BEEN THE PROFESSOR OF KAWHI
LEONARD AND KNOWING THAT HE'S
YEAR THAT HE SPENT IT'S AN EAGLE
STATE THAT.
BECAME TWO YEARS WAS NOT
SOMETHING HE WOULD HAVE EVER
WANTED TO DO -- AND THE SAME IS
TRUE WITH DIANA AND SO AS I LOOK
AT THIS AND I'M THINKING IS THIS
IS THE BEST INTEREST OF STUDENTS
KNOWS IN INVEST INTEREST OF
UNIVERSITY IN MAKING MONEY YES.
IT IS IN THE BEST INTERESTS OF
ACADEMICS NO -- BECAUSE THOSE OF
THAT'S NOT THE FOCUS OF A IT'S A
REALLY ABOUT MAKING LOTS OF
MONEY AND THE AND AS I LISTEN TO
THESE RULES.
A PARTICULARLY THE THE THE THE
THE ISSUES OF WHAT YOU CAN'T DO
BEGINNING IN HIGH SCHOOL AND
I'VE HAD SOME STUDENTS WHO WERE.
SOMEHOW ANOTHER VIçT SOMETHING
IN HIGH SCHOOL BECAME VERY BIG
BECAUSE THEY ACCEPTED SOMETHING
THAT THEY DIDN'T KNOW ANYTHING
ABOUT IT YET.
THEY'RE BEING HELD ACCOUNTABLE
TO THESE RULES IS IF YOU OWN
THESE PEOPLE.
AND OBVIOUSLY BEING AFRICAN
AMERICAN OWNING PEOPLE IS NOT
SOMETHING I'M REALLY -- IN FAVOR
OF HAVING US SURVIVED A BITE
ANSWERS TO SLAVERY IF THIS I'VE
ALWAYS FELT.
THIS WHOLE GAME THINGS LIKE BIG
SLAVE SYSTEM.
THAT OF THAT ROUTE DOESN'T ALLOW
YOU TO ACTUALIZE PLAY THE SPORT.
OF THE VERY SPORTS AND HE GOT
VERY LITTLE OUT OF IT.
MOST OF MY STUDENTS ALMOST LIVE
IN POVERTY WHILE THEY WERE ON
CAMPUS AS IT WERE COULDN'T EVEN
GET SOMEONE COULD GET FINANCIAL
AID THAT DIDN'T GET ADEQUATE
SCHOLARSHIP.
THEY COULD WORK IN THE SUMMER
THEY COULD WORK IN THE EVENINGS
THAT YOU KNOW AND THEY THEY JUST
USED EVERY MOMENT OF THEM.
IN ORDER -- TO PLAY THE SPORT
AND YET THEY WOULD NOT ABLE TO
MARKET THEMSELVES IN ANY KIND OF
MANNER IN ANY FASHION.
AND AND MANY OF THEM WERE NOT
GOING PRO SO THIS WAS A A TIME
IN THEIR LIFE WHEN THEY COULD
HAVE DONE SOMETHING AND THEN TO
SEE.
IN THE END THAT OUR UNIVERSITIES
WERE MAKING MORE AND MORE AND
MORE BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY THE FOCUS
IS IS IS GETTING ON TV AND
DRIVING EVERYTHING ELSE AND
MAKING.
MORE MONEY AND MORE MONEY AND
AND I MOST FACULTY ON CAMPUS
EVERY YEAR THERE WAS ALWAYS A
PROTEST OR EIGHT EFFORT TO
ELIMINATE SPORTS AT SAN DIEGO
STATE -- BECAUSE OF THE
TREMENDOUS MONEY THAT WAS COMING
INTO THE CAMPUS IS THAT WOULD
NOT BENEFITING STUDENTS.
OF THE HUGE SALARIES OF FACULTY
BEPPO THAT NOT FACULTY BUT
CULTURES WERE MAKING FAR ABOVE
THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNIVERSITY
OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS TO THE
CULTURES WHO RAN THE VERY SPORTS
AND IT'S JUST A HUGE MACHINE OF
ITSELF.
AND IN THE END WHEN I LOOK AT IT
MOST OF MY STUDENTS AND BENEFIT
FROM IT.
I PROBABLY HAD TO STUDENTS IN
ALL THE TIME HAVE BEEN IN WHO
REALLY BEEN REALLY SEARS PRO.
YOU KNOW AND YOU KNOW FOOTBALL
OF THE FOOTBALL PLAYER I MEAN
BASKETBALL C<c.cyan> ISLAND IT OF</c>
COURSE.
AND BLOCKING ON POINTED TOE AND
TONY GWYNN BASEBALL -- BEYOND
THAT THAT'S A FORTY YEAR HISTORY
OKAY THEN.
IF YOU WANTED -- TO SOMEWHERE
BUT YEAH BUT NOT REALLY SERIOUS
MONEY I MEAN YOU KNOW LIKE THOSE
TO THE ITSELF.
SO WHEN I BEGIN TO ASK MYSELF
THIS QUESTION AND WHEN IT WAS
BROUGHT TO ME I I SAID TO MYSELF
YOU KNOW WHO'S MAKING THE MONEY
ON THIS AND WE SEE IT EVERY DAY --
WE SEE IT IN SMALL WAYS AND IN
LARGE WAYS THIS CAMPUS CALCULATE
HOW MUCH THEY CAN MAKE ON THE
STUDENTS.
AND KNOWING THAT THE STUDENTS
WILL BENEFIT VERY LITTLE WHILE
THE BEER WHAT THE WHAT THE
PROMISE ALWAYS IF THEY WILL GO
PRO.
AND AND MANY OF THEM BELIEVE
THAT KNOWING THAT THEY DON'T
HAVE REALLY THE ABILITY IN A
COMPETITIVE LEVEL TO ACTUALLY GO
PRO -- I'VE SEEN SOME OF THE
WORST THINGS IN TERMS OF THAT
HAPPENED IN ATHLETICS I REALLY
HAVE AS A PROFESSOR.
OF ABUSE OF STUDENTS IN WAYS
THAT ONE COULD NOT IMAGINE AND
EVENTUALLY YOU COUPLE COACHES
WHO GOT -- KICKED OUT AND
STUDENT WHAT HAVE YOU BUT IN SEE
TO A COVER UP A LOT OF STUFF.
AND SO I JUST FIND IT APPALLING
WHEN I READ AND SAID THAT THEY
WILL BE THE EFFORT WOULD BE TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE STUDENTS.
A DID NOT PARTICIPATE ANYTHING
ELSE -- AND THEN WE'RE GOING TO
MAKE A DECISION ABOUT THEIR
LIVES BASED ON WHAT SCHOOL ARE
GOING TO GO TO IN WHO'S GOING TO
BE THE AND WHO'S NOT GOING TO BE
THERE AND WHAT MONEY IS GOING TO
BE THE AND ALL THAT OTHER KIND
OF STUFF BUT IT REALLY.
IS ABOUT THE PROTECTION AND SEE
TO IT AND PROTECTION OF CAMPUSES
AND THEIR ABILITY TO MAKE A LOTS
AND LOTS OF MONEY ON THE
STUDENTS.
AND THE AND THE STUDENTS TO
BENEFIT MOST OF THEM VERY LITTLE
FROM BEING COLLEGE ATHLETES YOU
KNOW MOST ATHLETES I KNOW NOW
DID NOT MAKE ANY MONEY AS A
RESULT OF BEING AN ATHLETE THAT
HAVE BENEFITTED VERY LITTLE.
IN THE PROCESS -- AND COULD THEY
HAVE DONE SOMEONE ELSE MAKES A
LITTLE BIT MORE MONEY MAYBE THEY
COULD HAVE.
BUT THE BUT THE RESTRICTION IS
SAYS YOU CAN'T DO IT.
IS WHAT I FIND TO BE HONEST MORE
THAN ANYTHING ELSE THE INABILITY
TO USE MY TALENT MY SKILL TO
MARKET MYSELF FOR MYSELF.
A WHILE OTHER TO DOING THAT IS
IS TO ME STILL AN UNACCEPTABLE
AND UP SO I'LL BE SUPPORTING
THIS BILL AND HOPEFULLY IN THE
TIME FRAME.
INTO TO A WILL SOMETIMES LOOK AT
ITSELF THIS CONVERSATION IS I
WOULD SAY PROBABLY OLDER THAN I
AM BUT IT'S NOT BECAUSE ONLY THE
LAST BY FIFTY SIXTY YEARS.
THAT WE REALLY BEEN RAKING IN
THE MONEY ON STUDENTS OF THAT
I'VE SEEN BUT IT IS AN OLD
CONVERSATION REALLY OLD OF THAT
PEOPLE TALK ABOUT IF
UNIVERSITIES PEOPLE TALK ABOUT.
IN COMMUNITIES ALL THE TIME IS
WHY CAN'T THE STUDENTS WHO OUT
THERE WORKING I MEAN IT
LITERALLY WORKING BECAUSE YOU
CONSUME.
THEIR DAYTIME ALL WE INTO THE
EVENING FROM EARLY MORNING TO
AFTER SPINAL SWIMMERS WHO HAD
THIS WITH A FOUR O'CLOCK EVERY
MORNING SAN DIEGO STATE.
GO TO CLASS AND COME BACK AND
EAT LUNCH OR WHATEVER AND THEN
SWIM CLOSE TO SIX TO SEVEN
O'CLOCK AT NIGHT -- AND AND AND
GET VERY LITTLE OUT OF IT. ONE
OF MY STUDENTS AT LESS THAN A
SEMESTER HAD MESSED UP ALL OF
HER MUSCLES IN HER LAKE AND
COULD NO LONGER SWIM AFTER AFTER
ONE SEMESTER IT'S AN EAGLE STATE.
AND SHE HAD NEVER TO TALK ABOUT
THE DIFFICULTY IN THE TASK OF
THE HARD WORK THAT WAS THERE --
AND IT'S A HARD JOB IT'S A HARD
JOB BEING AN ATHLETE AND IF YOU
YET AND AND AND THE DEMANDS ARE
GREAT.
NOT ONLY DO IN THE SEASON WHEN
YOU'RE DOING WITH OFF SEASON AND
SUMMER AS WELL AND IS VERY LOW
COMPENSATION THAT COMES TO THOSE
STUDENTS AND A FEW BECOME FAMOUS.
SO BE IT BUT THE REST OF THEM
ALL THEY GIVE AN AWFUL LOT AND
GET VERY LITTLE IN RETURN.
AND I THINK IT'S TIME TO
BASICALLY PUSHED THE AGENDA.
FOR AND TO MAKE SURE THAT -- NC.
TWO EIGHT TAKES A SERIOUS LOOK
AT ITSELF BECAUSE THIS HAD A
COMMITTEE TO DEAL WITH THIS
ISSUE.
OVER AND OVER AND OVER AGAIN
EVERY TIME THE TOPIC COMES UP IS
ALWAYS A DISCUSSION A WE'RE
GONNA FORM A COMMITTEE WE DO A
COMMITTEE WE GET A REPORT AND WE
STILL DON'T DO ANYTHING -- AND
AND STE AND AND WHO SUFFERS THE
MOST OF THE ATHLETES.
I'M OF THE BILL SECOND
[inaudible]
DOCTOR CHOI.
THANK YOU CHAIR AND THE SENATORS
SAW.
NOW THIS IS MY SECOND TIME.
AROUND HEARING.
AT THE FIRST TIME I COULD NOT
MAKE UP MY MIND THE AT THE ARTS
ENTERTAINMENT AS POST COMMITTEE --
AND THE LISTENING TO OR BOTH
SIDES OF OUR TESTIMONY -- MANY
QUESTIONS THAT I HAD THE OR ARE
NOW ANSWERED.
I HAD TWO MAJOR QUESTIONS AT
THAT TIME.
WAS GONNA HAPPEN.
IF BUT NOBODY YEARS SUCKED AT NC
DOUBLE A WE'RE INSIST UPON ON
THEIR CURRENT.
A RULES AND THE STEM CALIFORNIA.
INFOSYS ARE DIFFERENT RULED BY
PASSING THIS -- AND WAS GONNA BE
OF WHO'S GONNA WIN.
AND AT THE THERE WERE SOME
POTENTIAL THE ATHLETES SO WILL
GET HURT -- THAT WAS MY FEAR BUT
NOW.
LISTENING TO THE LAWYERS SO
INTERPRETATION I HOPE HIS
CRACKED THE THAT THAT HE HAS SO
MORE WINNING CHEN SO THAT GIVES
ME A LITTLE BIT OF WHAT
[inaudible]
STONE SO -- THE SECOND QUESTION
THAT I HAD WAS THAT SINCE THE
CURRENT THE IS IT TO A IS --
STARTING WITH THE TASK FORCE SO.
WHAT THE RULES THAT THEY CAN
CHANGE -- HOWEVER -- I GOT THE
END SO THAT THAT IT HAS BEEN FOR
A LONG TIME THEY'VE BEEN
ATTEMPTING ATTEMPTING TO CHANGE
BUT THAT HAS NOT BEEN.
NO DRASTIC CHANGE IT WAS THE THE
THE LITTLE BIT THAT LITTLE BIT
THAT NOT NOT SO MUCH OF OUR A
FRIEND SO FROM CURRENT PRACTICE.
AND THEN ALSO A READING -- OWNER --
CASES SO FOR STUDENTS -- BEING
PENALIZED.
WHO -- VIOLATED THE THE CURRENT
NC DOUBLE A AND THAT THIS OF
THOSE CHILDREN SO WHO -- COULD
OF MADE A LITTLE BIT OF MONEY
BUT WELL INTENDED CUP BUT THEY
WAS -- THE RULES.
OF VIOLATED -- AND THAT THEY
WERE BANNED IN THE NEXT BED THE
FROM THE MEMBERSHIP.
SO I I THINK -- WE EVEN THOUGH I
DO READ THAT THE AUTHORS --
INTENDING.
TO MAKE A NC DOUBLE A TO THINK
HARDER -- THAT THE DESIST TIME
AND TO MAKE THEM.
MOVE FORWARD AND IF WE I THINK
THAT THIS.
UP.
WILL DEFINITELY UP.
UP PROBLEM.
UP THROUGH -- TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY THREE UNTIL THE
IMPLEMENTATION TIME TO SAY
ENOUGH TIME.
AND THE WEATHER ALSO SO WOULD BE
PREPARED TO ALL OUR THE CHANGE
OF RULES MAY TAKE PLAYS SO.
ARE SO I I THINK THIS WOULD BE
COULD PROMPTER -- TO CHANGE THE
IN OCTOBER SITUATION THAT OUR
ATHLETES ARE.
OF PHASING SO WITH THEM MY
OBSERVATION ON HEARING AND THAT
THE I HAVE FOUND THE ANSWERS TO
THE QUESTIONS THAT HAD THE SO.
I WOULD LIKE -- TO CAST EIFFEL
TODAY [inaudible]
MR BLOOM.
MR SURE THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
WHEN I OF FOR STARTED THINKING
ABOUT -- TO ABOUT THIS BILL LIKE --
AND TALK TO BOTH SIDES I WAS
CONCERNED ABOUT THE TURMOIL THAT
THE THAT MAY WELL AND SU BY OUR
ACTIONS AND THE THOUGHT.
TO AS A RELATIVELY CAUTIOUS
PERSON TURMOIL MAYBE THAT'S NOT
SUCH A GOOD THING -- BUT I'M
CONVINCED TODAY THAT NOTHING'S
GOING TO CHANGE -- WITHOUT AT
LEAST THE POTENTIAL FOR SOME --
A FOR SOME A TERM OTHERS THAT
OLD SAYING THAT NOTHING NOTHING
GOOD EVER CAME WITHOUT A
STRUGGLE.
AND SOMETHING HAS TO GIVE HERE I
THINK THAT -- OF THOSE OF YOU
WHO ARE HERE PARTICIPATING IN
THIS HEARING ARE ARE HEARING.
A FROM AROUND THE DICE THE SENSE
THAT -- THE STATUS QUO IS
UNACCEPTABLE AND SOMETHING NEEDS
TO CHANGE AND THERE'S A SENSE OF
GREAT FRUSTRATION I THINK
JUSTIFIABLY.
BOB WITH THE FACT THAT THIS
ISSUE'S BEEN PERCOLATING FOR
QUITE SOME TIME NOW.
AND VERY LITTLE HAS CHANGED.
SO I'M GONNA ASK A CAST MIKE --
I VOTE TODAY AS AS WELL -- AND
HOPE THAT.
THAT IS GOING TO HELP DRIVE --
NOT MAYBE A PERHAPS NOT EXACTLY
THE CHANGE THAT I THINK IS BEST --
THAT THE AUTHOR THINKS IS BEST --
BUT THAT HELPS THE MOST PEOPLE
WHO ARE -- REALLY I THINK THE
PEOPLE THAT THE AUTHORS TRYING
TO TO HELP HERE OF THE OF THOSE
ATHLETES WHO ARE UNABLE -- TO
ACCESS FUNDS THAT -- OUR SCHOOLS
ARE ACCESSING QUITE EASILY.
I I WOULD LIKE TO SUGGEST.
THAT -- OF THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA.
AND THE CSU SYSTEM.
STAND UP AND AND TAKE A
LEADERSHIP ROLE ON THIS ISSUE --
I'M NOT HEARING THAT.
TODAY. FIVE I WOULD ENCOURAGE
THE REGENTS -- TO CONSIDER THIS
ISSUE AND TAKE A POSITION ON IT
AND PROVIDE SOME LEADERSHIP
RATHER THAN -- FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE I THINK THERE'S
WHAT'S HAPPENING NOW IS -- WHO
WERE WAITING FOR THINGS TO
HAPPEN AND NOT -- TO HELPING TO
A DRIVE THE ISSUE FORWARD
[inaudible]%
SO -- I HOPE TO HEAR WITH ANNA
AND I HOPE THAT THAT'S GONNA
HAPPEN IN A SHORT PERIOD OF TIME
I HOPE THAT WE'R NOT GOING TO
BE HERE -- IN TWENTY TWENTY
THREE ARE CLOSE -- TO TWENTY
TWENTY THREE AND THERE'S FEVERS
NEGOTIATIONS HAPPENING AT THAT
POINT IN TIME LET'S NOT WAIT
LET'S LET'S DEAL WITH THE ISSUE
NOW AND MOVE SOMETHING FORWARD
IN THAT IN THE NEAR TERM IF IT'S
GOING TO BE COMPROMISED.
THANK YOU -- AND IF I MAY WITH
THE I'M GONNA MAKE SOME COMMENTS
AND THEN I'LL GO BACK TO THE
SENATORS FOR THEIR CLOSING --
THANK YOU TO ALL THE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE FOR VERY --
INSIGHTFUL AND QUESTIONS AND
COMMENTS I I WOULD SAY WHEN I
FIRST.
HAD A THE ISSUE IN FRONT OF ME I
SHARED OF MY COLLEAGUES --
MISTER PATTERSON IS A CONCERN OF
WHAT EFFECT WILL THIS HAVE.
ON ON COLLEGE SPORTS AND AND I
JUST WANT TO SHARE THAT I HAD TO
COLLEGE EXPERIENCES.
BOTH VERY DIFFERENT FROM THE
OTHER I STARTED MY COLLEGE
CAREER -- AT A BIG TEN
UNIVERSITY -- IN INDIANA AT
PURDUE UNIVERSITY DIVISION ONE
WHERE I SHARED CLASSES IN LATIN
AMERICAN HISTORY WITH THE MANY
ATHLETES FOOTBALL PLAYERS TRACK
PLAYERS BASKETBALL PLAYERS
MATTER OF FACT.
HAD THE FEELING THAT I'M MIGHT
HAVE BEEN ONE OF THE FEW NON
ATHLETES IN THE CLASS.
BUT I ALSO ENJOYED THE THE LEVEL
OF COMPETITIONA BIG TEN
UNIVERSITY AND FOOTBALL AND
BASKETBALL.
AND AND HAD ONE EXPERIENCE AT
THAT PURDUE UNIVERSITY AND THEN
TRANSFERRED TO THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA.
AT RIVERSIDE THAT WAS THEN
DIVISION.
TWO HAD A FOOTBALL TEAM THAT
THAT THE STUDENTS -- VOTED TO
END IN NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR THE
YEAR I GRADUATED.
AND AND CERTAINLY WAS NOT THE
SAME -- EXPERIENCE AS A AS A BIG
TEN UNIVERSITY OF THAT PRODUCE
AS BOTH WERE VERY VALUABLE BUT
BOTH.
WERE VERY DIFFERENT AND AND TO
DOCTOR WEBER WE CONTINUE TO HAVE
THOSE DISCUSSIONS ON ON THE
VALUE OF THAT HAVE.
ATHLETICS ON THE STUDENT BODY
AND STUDENT BODIES MAKE
DIFFERENT DECISIONS. TO THIS
ISSUE THAT I REALLY WASN'T ALL
THAT FAMILIAR WITH -- WHEN THE
THE BILL CAME TO MY COMMITTEE?
I REACHED OUT TO THOSE FOLKS WHO
I KNEW THAT HAD PLAYED IN
ATHLETICS.
I I WENT AND I READ -- KAREEM
ABDUL JABBAR'S COMMENTS OF HIM
GOING HUNGRY.
AS A COLLEGE STUDENT AT UCLA AS
WITH WHEN HE PLAYED BASKETBALL
AT UCLA AND AND YOU KNOW I I WAS.
SURPRISED.
BY THAT COMMENT.
I I WENT TO MY FORMER NEIGHBOR.
SAM NIGHT WHO PLAYED BASKETBALL
FOR RIVERSIDE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
I THINK YOU MAY HAVE PLAYED FOR
COACH TARKANIAN -- WHEN
UNDERLYING BEACH AND THEN THE U.
N. L. V. HE HAD THREE SONS?
HE HAD THREE SONS ALL OF WHOM
WHO PLAYED FOOTBALL AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA ALL OF THEM RUNNING
BACKS AT USC.
AND THEN THE FATHER SAM WAS MY
MY NEIGHBOR DOWN THE STREET AND
I SAID SAM WHAT DO YOU THINK
ABOUT THIS.
YOU KNOW WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT
THIS ISSUE.
AND HE SHARED WITH ME VERY
HONESTLY.
THAT AS A FATHER OF THOSE THREE
ATHLETES HE WOULD HAVE BEEN VERY
HAPPY IF HIS SONS WOULD HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO BENEFIT.
MATTER OF FACT ONE OF HIS SONS
THE OLDEST IN THE FIRST ONE TO
PLAY IT AT USC CAME ON THE LINE
AND SAID THAT HE WOULD SUPPORT
THIS.
AS WELL TO A PERSON.
THERE WAS NO ONE THAT I TALKED
TO WHETHER THEY WERE HIGH SCHOOL
COACHES OUR FORMER ATHLETES.
HAD OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL.
SO I I THINK THAT -- THE BILL IS
IS DEFINITELY WHAT IS NEEDED --
THAT THE NC DOUBLE A NEEDS TO
TAKE A HARD LOOK AT ITSELF.
THAT -- IT IS TIME THAT WE GIVE
ATHLETES WHAT IS FAIR.
AND YOU CAN NOT ASK I DON'T
THINK ATHLETES WERE COACHES MAKE
ALMOST HALF A MILLION DOLLARS
AND BRING MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
INTO A PROGRAM.
NOT TO BENEFIT FROM THEIR WHAT
THEY ARE DOING.
SO I THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD AND I
WILL BE SUPPORTING IT -- THIS
AFTERNOON.
AND WITH THAT -- CENTER SKINNER
IF YOU'D LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WE HAD A GOOD DISCUSSION
IT'S INTERESTING THAT YOU
REFERENCED KAREEM ABDUL JABBAR
BECAUSE HE WAS THE FIRST PERSON
THAT I HEARD TO REALLY BRING
THIS TO MY ATTENTION AND WE'RE
TALKING BACK IN THE SEVENTIES.
AND THEN I HAD THE BENEFIT OF AT
CAL -- LISTENING TO LECTURES BY
PROFESSOR HARRY EDWARDS
SOCIOLOGIST WHO OF COURSE HAS
CHAMPION THIS NOW FOR A GOOD
FIFTY YEARS.
AND YOU CAN'T HELP IF YOU WOULD
LISTEN TO ANY SPORTS CHANNEL ANY
COMMENTATORS ATHLETES THEY
REFERENCE THIS ALL THE TIME SO
AND THEY HAVE FOR YEARS.
SO I THINK -- AS HAS BEEN
POINTED OUT THE NOTION THAT
SOMEHOW THE NC TWO EIGHT JUST
NEEDS A LITTLE MORE TIME.
WE ARE GIVING IT TO THEM BUT
THEY HAVE CERTAINLY HAD AMPLE --
THERE IS A CONGRESSIONAL BILL
RIGHT NOW CONGRESS MEMBER MARK
WALKER REPUBLICAN CONGRESS
MEMBER CEDRIC RICHMOND A
DEMOCRAT HAVE INTRODUCED A BILL.
TO DO ALMOST IDENTICAL TO THIS
IT'S GOING TO CONGRESS THERE ARE
OTHER STATES WERE LOOKING THIS
IS A NATIONAL CONVERSATION IT'S
NOT GOING AWAY.
AND I THINK IT IS -- IT IS
SOMETHING THAT CALIFORNIA DOES
WHICH IS LEADS WE HAVE MUCH
EXPERIENCE WITH HELPING TO BE
THE CATALYST FOR IMPORTANT
CHANGE WE ALSO HAVE MUCH
EXPERIENCE WITH ARMAGEDDON
THREATS.
FROM ENTRENCHED INTERESTS
CORPORATIONS UP AND DOWN THE
STATE SAID THEY'D LEAVE OUR
STATE WHEN WE DEMANDED GENDER
PAY EQUITY THEY HAVE NOT LEFT --
THERE'S BEEN THREATS OF JOB LOSS
AND ECONOMIC DOOM WHEN WE
ADOPTED OUR BOLD.
CLIMATE PROTECTION LAWS WE ARE
THE FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE
WORLD WE'VE WE STOOD THOSE
CONSEQUENCES OR THREATS AND DIE
WITH THAT -- I WOULD TURN TO MY
A JOINT AUTHOR AND OF COURSE I
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU AND I ALSO WANT TO
THANK ALL THE MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE AND THE WITNESSES FOR
THE GREAT DISCUSSION AND DEBATE
AS IT RELATES TO THIS ISSUE.
AND AS I SAID HERE I THOUGHT
ABOUT MY SIXTEEN YEARS OF
COACHING FOOTBALL AND BASEBALL --
BEFORE IT MADE IT TO THE
LEGISLATURE AND I USED TO TALK
TO THE YOUNG.
MEN WHO ARE WERE ALREADY AT TEN
TWELVE THIRTEEN IN TRAVEL CLUBS
AND PARENTS SCRAMBLING TO HIRE
TRAINERS AND COACHES AND THESE
KIDS WERE POORLY IDA.
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL JUST GOING TO
MIDDLE SCHOOL AND THEY WERE
ALREADY BEING PURSUED BY.
COACHES AND LIKE YOU SAY TRAVEL
CLUBS AND THE COST OF PLAYING A
GAME THAT THEY LOVED AND HOW
PARENTS SCRAMBLED.
SCRAPE TOGETHER JUST TO KEEP
THEIR KIDS COMPETITIVE I
REMEMBER WRITING A CHECK TO IT A
FAMILY SO THERE KEY IT COULD GO
TO A TOURNAMENT UP IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
ADD.
I LISTEN TO THESE PARENTS AND I
USED TO TELL THE STUDENTS IF YOU
GET NOTHING OUT OF SPORTS.
GET A COLLEGE EDUCATION.
BUT IT'S THERE IN COLLEGE WHERE
THESE ATHLETES ARE BEING
EXPLOITED THE MOST.
I ATTENDED SAN DIEGO STATE AS
DOCTOR WEBER STATED I WENT TO
SCHOOL WITH TONY GOING AND I
WENT TO SCHOOL WOOD BURNING DEAN
ANYONE ON THE PLANET SUPER BOWL.
CLINT SAMPSON WHO PLAYED IN
SUPER BOWL MICHAEL CAGE PLAYED
IN THE NBA BUT MANY OF THESE
ATHLETES WHILE ON CAMPUS
STRUGGLE.
JUST TO KEEP.
THE LIGHTS ARE ON FOOD ON THEIR
PLATES.
AND IF THEY HAD A CAR LEGACY GAS
IN THEIR CAR THESE ATHLETES EVEN
ON SCHOLARSHIP WERE STRUGGLING.
AND THIS IS ABOUT.
AS WE STATED FAIRNESS AND THE NC
TO A HAS HIT THEIR HEAD IN THE
SAND FOR FAR TOO LONG.
THERE ARE ANTIQUATED BILLION
DOLLAR INDUSTRY THAT IS USED
ATHLETES PRIMARILY AFRICAN
AMERICAN ATHLETES AS CHATTEL.
FOR OVER FIFTY YEARS AND THE
ONLY REASON WE HAVE THE TERM OF
STUDENT ATHLETE WAS TO DENY
EIGHT INJURED ATHLETES IN THE
FIFTIES MEDICAL BENEFITS FOR
KNEE INJURY THAT COLLEGE DID NOT
WANT TO PAY.
SO THE NCAA IS THE REASON WHY
WE'RE HERE TODAY.
BECAUSE YOU HAVE FAILED TO DEAL
WITH THIS ISSUE OF FAIRNESS.
AND AT THE SAME TIME THE
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES WERE
PUT THEIR HANDS UP.
THAT'S ARE YOU SEE AND YOU A CSU.
YOU ARE THE BOSS OF THE NC TO
LET YOU MAKE UP WHAT THE NCAA IS
SO IT'S UP TO YOU THE RAISE YOUR
VOICE.
AS OUR GOVERNOR STATED.
CALIFORNIA'S THE NEXT COMING
ATTRACTIONS.
THIS IS A FINE EXAMPLE OF
CALIFORNIA LEADING THE WAY AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL.
I WANTED THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
HER -- WILLINGNESS TO ACCEPT THE
AMENDMENTS AS OUTLINED ON PAGE
NINE OF THE HOUSES THAT WILL
WILL GE I BELIEVE WILL BE TAKEN
AND ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS.
LOOKS I LOOK FORWARD TO CLOSELY
MONITORING THE ISSUE IN THE
COMING YEARS AND HOLDING AN
OVERSIGHT HEARING.
ON THE NC DOUBLE A WORKING
GROUP'S FINDINGS AFTER THEY ARE
PUBLISHED IN OCTOBER.
OF SO WE HAD A MOTION BY.
DOCTOR WEBER A SECOND BY MR
GABRIEL'S MAN SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED
TO THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEDINA HI MEDINA I CHOI.
CHOI I ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA I BLOOM.
BLOOM I GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I IRWIN -- WHEN I KILEY?
KILEY I LEVINE.
LEVINE I LOW [inaudible]
PATTERSON.
PATTERSON NOT VOTING SANTIAGO.
WEBER.
WEBER I SIGNATURE MEMBERS THAT
WAS A NINE ZERO YOUR BILL IS OUT
THANK YOU SENATORS AND WE WILL
LEAVE THAT OPEN FOR ANY ABSENT
MEMBERS.
NEXT ITEM.
TO S. C. R. TWENTY NINE SENATOR
LABOR.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
A MUCH SHORTER AND SIMPLER BILL
OR IF I'M IN A BILL -- BUT I
WILL SAY I DID NOT GO TO SCHOOL
WITH TONY GWYNN BUT HIS DAUGHTER
MY BOUGHT DAUGHTER PLAYED
BASKETBALL TOGETHER IN HIGH
SCHOOL.
AT ONTARIO CHRISTIAN HIGH SCHOOL.
FROM VERY NICE IS A YEAH.
OKAY THANK YOU THANK YOU ARE
WILL GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU
FOR HAVING ME TODAY -- S. C. R.
TWENTY NINE WOULD RECOGNIZE JUNE
TWENTY SEVENTH TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN AS THE ANNIVERSARY OF
THE UNIVERSITY COUNCIL AMERICAN
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS YOU SEE
A. F. T..
REPRESENTATION OF LIBRARIANS
THIS RESOLUTION.
ALSO COMMENSAL LIBRARIANS
REPRESENTED BY YOU SEE A OF T.
FOR THE GREAT CONTRIBUTIONS TO
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA YOU
SEE LIBRARIANS WORKED TIRELESSLY
TO PROVIDE STUDENTS AND FACULTY
WITH COLLECTION MATERIALS.
COMPREHENSIVE RESEARCH AND
TECHNICAL SUPPORT THESE
LIBRARIANS UPHOLD THE PRESTIGE
OF THE UC AS A NATION LEADING
RESEARCH INSTITUTION AND EMBODY
THE PUBLIC MISSION OF THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA.
AT SEA ARE TWENTY NINE
HIGHLIGHTS THE CONTRIBUTIONS OF
THE U. S. THE UC A OF TEA AND
IT'S MORE THAN THREE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY YOU SEE LIBRARIANS AS
WELL AS RECOGNIZES THEIR EFFORTS
TO SECURE ADEQUATE COMPENSATION.
AND BENEFITS THAT REFLECT THEIR
VALUE TO THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA AND JUST YOU KNOW WE
LOVE OUR LIBRARIANS THEY DO SUCH
GREAT WORK THEY HELP.
STUDENTS YOUNG AND OLD KNOW WHAT
THEY NEED TO KNOW SO THEY CAN DO
WELL AND ACHIEVE THEIR BASS SO
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE MOVED A BILL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU AND I'VE
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT SHOULD YOU
WANT TO HEAR FROM THEM.
MR MEMBERS BRIAN HOW THE
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS I WANT TO ECHO -- THE
SENATOR'S COMMENTS AND I REALLY
DO APPRECIATE HER LEADERSHIP AND
TAKEN ON THIS RESOLUTION --
LIBRARIANS ARE VERY IMPORTANT TO
OUR UC SYSTEM AND IT'S IT
HAPPENS TO BE ONE OF THE FASTEST
GROWING BARGAINING UNITS OF THE
STATE.
OF IRAQ DRIVE VOTE THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS JOHN RUN DIDN'T R. U.
N. D. I. N. AND I AM THE P. OF
LEGISLATION FOR THE UC F. T..
THE UNION THAT REPRESENTS
LIBRARIANS AND LECTURES AT THE
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA I IMPACT
ON LECTURE NOT A LIBRARIAN BUT
AS A SCHOLAR MYSELF I'M COMPLETE
DEPENDED ON THE LIBRARIANS.
THEY FIND THE STUFF I NEED TO
KNOW EFFICIENTLY AND WELL I HAVE
TO SAY -- A CENTER LEYVA
MENTIONED THAT THERE'S SUPPORT
OF THE STUDENTS.
IT'S ALSO POINT TO REALIZE
THEY'RE ABSOLUTELY VITAL TO THE
RESEARCH IN THE LIBRARY.
FACULTY MEMBERS ALSO RELY ON
LIBRARIES LIBRARIANS ARE AT THE
CORE OF OUR INFORMATION SOCIETY.
AND THEY WORK TIRELESSLY AND
SELFLESSLY TO PROMOTE THE
MISSION OF THE UNIVERSITY AND TO
BENEFIT OUR ENTIRESTATE THANK
YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
ANY TWEETERS [inaudible]
DOCTOR CHOI.
THANK YOU CHAIR.
US SENATOR LEYVA I'M A LIBRARIAN
CAN YOU ADD ME AS TO OUR CALL
CENTER.
THANK YOU FOR RECOGNIZING MY
PROFESSION YOU'RE WELCOME. FOR
WHAT YOU DO.
ALSO A LIBRARIAN AT THE NEWPORT
BEACH PUBLIC LIBRARY IN THE ALSO
A PROFESSOR AT THE U. S. C. AT
THE GRADUATE SCHOOL OF LIBRARY
AND INFORMATION MANAGEMENT.
FROM PITTSBURGH WELL THANK YOU I
DO NOT IF I'M FINALLY TIME THIS
COME AND ALLOWED [inaudible]
AND THE AND THE RECOGNIZE --
LIBRARIANS WORKING AND THEN --
YOU AND I CAN WORK UP I WOULD
LIKE TO I AM WORKING NOT VERY
HARD BEFORE I LEFT A IT NOW SEE
IF IRVINE -- THAT THE OLD ONE OF
THE RICHEST OF TOWNIES SO OUT IN
THE STATE.
ACCOUNTABLE ORANGEY IS THE ONE
NOT WITHOUT.
THE MAY NOT LIBRARY AND IRVINE
HAS LAND AND THE MONEY.
AND THAT THAT WAS.
NO -- POLITICAL WE ARE ALL EVEN
SO WE HAD THE MONEY AND THE LAND
THAT THOUGH -- ORANGE COUNTY
GREAT PARK AND ON ON TRYING TO
STEAL.
AND PUSH THAT IDEA AND THE BUILT
UP OVER.
TWO HUNDRED THOUSANDS
COMFORTABLE LIBRARY MAYBE YOU
CAN HELP ME.
AND THAT THE LET ME KNOW. TO
WRITE A LETTER I'D BE GLAD TO
HELP.
IT IS MY NEIGHBORING COUNTY YEAH --
BE HAPPY TO BE HERE ARE YOUR
PRINTS FOR COURT.
THANK YOU CAPTION IS ARE BLUE --
THANK YOU FOR GIVING ME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRAISE MR CHOI.
WE'RE HERE TO HELP ON THE LEYVA
THE QUITE SIMPLY I THINK
LIBRARIANS ARE UNSUNG HEROES OF
OUR OF OUR COMMUNITIES AND OUR
AND OUR SCHOOLS.
OF THEY ARE -- CENTRAL TO A TO
OUR LEARNING SYSTEMS OF THEIR
CENTRAL TO OUR SOCIAL SERVICE
SYSTEMS BECAUSE THEY PROVIDE
SERVICE TO EVERYONE IN THE
COMMUNITY -- INCLUDING THE
DISPOSSESSED -- IN FACT I THINK
THAT'S ONE OF THEIR MOST
ESSENTIAL SERVICES -- DAY
WORKING A CONSTANTLY EVOLVING
ENVIRONMENT WHAT WE THOUGHT OF
AS LIBRARY SERVICES -- BACK WHEN --
WHEN I WAS YOUNG IS COMPLETELY
DIFFERENT BUT ALSO INCLUDE SOME
OF THAT -- FROM FROM WHAT IT IS
TODAY. FIVE AND THE UP FOR THAT
WE LIBRARIANS A DATA GRATITUDE
SO THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD INDEED THANK YOU.
EVERY YEAR -- WHEN I GET AN
OPPORTUNITY TO READ ACROSS
AMERICA I I READ ONE BOOK I TAKE
THE SAME BOOK YEAR AFTER YEAR?
AND THE BOOK IS TOMAS AND THE
LIBRARY LADY.
THAT'S ALSO AND TOMAS IN THE
LIBRARY LADY IS THE STORY OF
TOMAS RIVERA.
THE FIRST LATINO CHANCELLOR IN
THE UC SYSTEM AND HIS LOVE OF
READING AND THE HELP THAT HE GOT
FROM THE LIBRARY AND WHEN HE WAS
A MIGRANT WORKER -- I'M KINDA
NERDY SO SOME OF MY FAVORITE
PLACES ARE LIBRARIES AND WHETHER
IT'S BUTLER LIBRARY AT COLUMBIA
UNIVERSITY.
OR ROBERT FROST LIBRARY AT
AMHERST COLLEGE OR LOVE LIBRARY
AT SAN DIEGO STATE THOSE ARE
SOME OF THE BEST TIMES I'VE HAD.
READING AND WITH THE HELP AS YOU
SAID OF THOSE LIBRARIANS SO I
ALSO WAS ASKED TO BE A CO AUTHOR
YOU GOT IT AND THANK ALL
LIBRARIANS WHETHER THERE ARE
PUBLIC LIBRARY ANSWER.
YOU SEE HERE CSU LIBRARIANS FOR
THE WORK THEY DO.
AGREED THANK YOU SO WE HAD A
MOTION IT WHICH WILL.
CENTER WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR I VOTE FOR
FOR LIBRARIANS EVERYWHERE.
WE HAD A MOTION BY MISTER BLUE.
AND A SECOND BY MISTER LEVINE MR
GABRIEL AND MISTER CHOI.
STAND OUT OF SECRETARY IF YOU'D
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS BE ADOPTED TO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR MEDINA AYE
MEDINA AYE CHOI HI CHOI I
ARAMBULA [inaudible]
BLOOM.
BLOOM I GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I IRWIN -- WHEN I KILEY?
LEVINE LEVINE I LOW.
LOW I PATTERSON.
PATTERSON EYES SANTIAGO WEBER
[inaudible]
WEBER II. NINE ZERO THE BILL IS
OUT WE WILL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR
ANY ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU MEMBERS
THANK YOU SENATOR
. FOR AN OPEN
THE ROLE FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
ITEM ONE SP.
TWO OH SIX LOW LOW I SANTIAGO
[inaudible]
THE MINIMUM
THE ROLE OPEN FOR
FIVE MINUTES FOR THE ABSENT
MEMBERS
.
ITEM ONE SB TWO OH SIX SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO I'D [inaudible] ELEVEN
ZERO SB TWO OH SIX IS OUT.
I THEM TO A C. R. TWENTY NINE
ARAMBULA.
KILEY SANTIAGO SANTIAGO HI. TEN
ZERO S. C. R. TWENTY NINE IS OUT.
AND WE WILL KEEP THE ROLE OPEN
FOR AN ADDITIONAL TWO MINUTES.
WAITING FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
.
OR DO WE GET.
SB TWO OH SIX ELEVEN ZERO THE
BILL IS OUT.
S. C. R..
TWENTY NINE TEN ZERO THAT IS OUT
[inaudible]
WE'RE JR